DIVERSE INTERESTS REPRESENTED BY
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE I'VE
ALSO INVITED MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE TO JOIN US
TODAY AND EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T
HAVE A LARGE REPRESENTATION
RIGHT NOW IN PERSON I DO BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO ARE
OBSERVING- THROUGH ASSUME TODAY
WE'RE GONNA BE DISCUSSING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
STRATEGIES AND WE ARE
PRESENTATIONS FROM A WIDE
VARIETY OF PEOPLE WORKING IN
THIS SPACE. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU IN
TRYING TO DEVELOP COMMUNITIES
THAT MINIMIZE AND EVEN OFFSET
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
ADDRESS EQUITY ISSUES PROVIDE UP
ROBUST PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS HOUSING
NEEDS ARE MET I YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON SINCE COMING TO CHAIR
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
FROM NATURAL RESOURCES IS MAKING
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN A LOT OF THESE DIFFERENT
ISSUES TRANSPORTATION HOUSING
CLIMATE. EQUITY ISSUES ARE ALL
PARTS OF THE SAME ISSUE RELATING
TO CLIMATE CHANGE- CLIMATE
CHANGE IS CONNECTION TO HOW WE
LIVE EVERY DAY IN CALIFORNIA AND
RECOGNIZING THAT TO REALLY
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO RETHINK IN MANY
CASES HOW WE LIVE. AND HOW WE
PLAN FOR GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT.
OF THE HEARING ROOM IS OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING SO IF
YOU'RE IN YOUR SHOT OF THIS AND
YOU WANT TO COME ALIVE IN PERSON
YOU ARE MORE THAN WELCOME TO DO
SO- WE ARE ENCOURAGING YOU TO
WEAR A MASK WHILE IN THE
BUILDING BUT OF COURSE IT IS NO
LONGER. REQUIRED AND WE DO
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BY VISITING
OUR COMMITTEES WEBSITE. A NOTE
THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE IS
CONSIDERED PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAYBE READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED. EVERYONE IS
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE. AND YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON IN THE HEARING
ROOM OR BY USING OURTELEPHONE
SERVICE EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
COMMENT WHICH IS. A 100% MORE
THAN WE NORMALLY GET FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT STARTING WITH THOSE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
HERE IN THIS ROOM. TO USE OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE THE NUMBER TO
CALL IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
SEVEN AND THAT'S 877-692-8950
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN FORTY TWO OH
TWO. FOR WITNESSES CALLING INTO
THE PHONE LINE YOU WILL BE
PLACED IN A QUEUE INTO YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE MUTE YOUR DEVICE
TO REDUCE SOUND DISTORTIONS. IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATED FROM SERVICE YOU
CAN TRY CALLING THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY THREE AND
OUR STAFF WILL TRY TO HELP YOU.
FINALLY THE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO THE COMEDIAN FOR
FLOOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS. CONDUCT THAT JUST
DROPS A DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. SUCH CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING LONGER
THAN THE TIME ALLOTTED. EXTENDED
DISCUSSIONS OF MATTERS NOT
RELATING TO THE SUBJECT OF OUR
HEARING AND OTHER DISRUPTIVE
ACTS. ACTS TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE COMP THE CONDUCT ALL
TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WARN THEM THAT CONTINUE
TO DROP THIS MAY RESULT IN
REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. I WILL ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD OF THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED IN THE NATURE OF THE
CONDUCT I MAY TEMPLAR
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT DOES NOT
STOP I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
EXCLUDING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COOPERATION AND WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN. THE
HEARING. SO AS WE ALL KNOW
CLIMATE CHANGE IS HERE AND WE'RE
BEYOND JUST PREVENTING IT WE'RE
SEEING THE IMPACT EVERY SINGLE
DAY HERE AND AROUND THE WORLD.
AND WE HAVE UNDER DISCUSSED IN
UNDER CONSIDERED AN ADAPTATION
TO CLIMATE CHANGE. NOT TO MEAN
THAT WE SHOULDN'T STILL MAKE
ADVANCES IN GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS. UP BUDGET WE KNOW
ALSO THAT MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES WHICH HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN UNDER
INVESTED ARE BEARING THE WORST
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. AND
WILL DO SO IF NOT PRIORITISED.
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES ARE
AREAS THAT ARE ENJOYABLE AND
SAFE TO LIVE IN. WHILE ALSO
PROVIDE EASY ACCESS TO JOBS
HEALTHCARE EDUCATION
ENTERTAINMENT AND COMMERCE.
CONSIDER WALKING AND BIKING TO
ALL NECESSARILY SERVICES
UNNECESSARY SERVICES WITHIN
FIFTEEN MINUTES WALL BREATHING
CLEAN AIR AND CONTRIBUTING TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. OUR SUCH AS THE
WALKING AND BIKING IT'S ALSO THE
IDEA THAT YOU SHOULD ALSO BE
WITHIN A FIFTEEN MINUTE PUBLIC
TRANSIT RIDE. OF ALL OF THE SAME
SERVICES. CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPLICITLY FOCUSED ON BUILDING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES WITH
LEGISLATION LEGISLATIVE ACTION
SINCE TWO UP TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
WHEN SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE WAS
ENACTED. THAT BILL REQUIRES
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONSIDER LAND
USE DECISIONS IN ORDER TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THROUGH
REDUCTION IN VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. THE CROSS CUTTING
NATURE OF SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES EXPLICITLY REQUIRES
ACTION FROM AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE INCLUDING TRANSPORTATION
AND HOUSING. CURRENT PLANS OFTEN
DO NOT PROVIDE EXPLICIT ROADMAPS
ARE MOVING FORWARD WHICH LEADS
TO A LACK OF COORDINATION
BETWEEN AGENCIES IN THE PLANNING
PROCESS AND A DIFFERENCE IN
UNDERSTANDING ACROSS THE STATE.
BY THOSE AGENCIES IN WHAT IS
LEGISLATIVELY REQUIRED. A LACK
OF THE LACK OF FISCAL CONSTRAINT
IN PLANTS OFTEN CREATES ELECTIVE
IMPACT ON INVESTMENT DECISIONS.
IT'S GONNA TAKE ADVOCATES
AGENCIES AND POLITICAL WILL IN
THE HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH AREAS TO CREATE
TRULY SUSTAINABLE AND LIVABLE
COMMUNITIES FOR EVERYONE. WE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE THE RE SOURCE
AND THE COUPLE. TO ACHIEVE THIS
AMBITIOUS GOAL TODAY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN UP THE
DISCUSSION REGARDING ALIGNMENT
OF THESE RESOURCES AND THE
CREATION OF A ROAD MAP FOR MORE
SUCCESSFUL CREATIONS OF
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES. NOW I
AM VERY HAPPY TO SEE MY
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEX
LEE HERE AND I WANTED TO KNOW IF
HE HAS ANY COMMENTS- AS WE MOVE
INTO THE BEGINNING OF THE
HEARING. YES THANK YOU SO MUCH-
FRIEDMAN FOR ORGANIZING THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE VERY EXCITED TO
HEAR FROM OUR PANEL TODAY. ABOUT
HOW WE CAN USE THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT TO ADVANCE OUR GOALS
OF PROTECTING THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT. I'M A STRONG
BELIEVER THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE. A
GREAT AMENITIES OF A WALKABLE
COMMUNITY OR TRANSPARENCY
THROUGH MEANS THAT WE ENJOY WE
GONNA VACATIONS TO EUROPE OR
ASIA. SO IT'S SOMETHING. THAT IS
THAT YOU OF COURSE DEVELOPED
WORLD AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ALIGNING OURSELVES TO
FUTURE. SPECIAL LOOK AT OUR LAND
USE PATTERNS ASSEMBLY SAID TO BE
HERE TODAY YOU. THANK YOU AND
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU ARE
HERE WITH US TODAY. TODAY WE
HAVE THREE PANELS WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE FIRST AND SECOND
PANEL. I NEVER GONNA HAVE MEMBER
QUESTION AND ANSWERS. TO COVER
BOTH PANELS- I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
OUR FIRST SPEAKER TODAY TO
DISCUSS DISCUSS SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES. DR STEFANIE PEN.
PEN CELTIQUE. CONCEPTUAL WHO'S A
PHD ARM CHAIR OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING. AND THE
FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CENTER OF SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES AT UCLA- WELCOME DR
AND I BELIEVE SHE'S GOING TO BE
WITH US A BUYER- ASSUME CORRECT.
GREAT YEAH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I'M A BIG ADMIRER OF YOUR
OLD. CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR
YOU AND SEE YOU AND WELCOME AND
THANKS AGAIN FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO BE WITH US ALL THANK YOU- I
WAS JUST GONNA SAY WHAT A BEGIN
MEYER I AM OF YOURS SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IT'S REALLY.
INSPIRING AND GIVES US A LOT OF
HOPE ABOUT THE FUTURE. SO I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO COME TO FRAME
THIS- BEGINNING OF THIS
DISCUSSION- MY BACKGROUND IS IN
LAND USE I WROTE A BOOK ON THE
POLITICAL HISTORY OF LAND USE
THE STATE OF WORKED ON VARIOUS.
ISSUES OF HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING OR JUST RECENTLY
PUBLISHED A PAPER ON NEW HALL
RANCH- AND I'M A NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN SO THESE ISSUES ARE
ARE NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART.
SO I GREATLY WELCOME. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE SOME REMARKS
ABOUT LAND USE AND LAND USE
CHANGE. AND STATE TO FRAME THIS
DISCUSSION. SO AS I WAS- WAS
SAID EARLIER LAND USE AND LAND
DEVELOPMENT IT IS- THEY ARE A
KEY COMPONENT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THEY AFFECT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS EXPOSURE TO HEAT AND
FIRE CARBON SEQUESTRATION
ECOLOGICAL BIODIVERSITY
AGRICULTURE. EXPOSURES TO HIGH
HEAT AND NEARLY EVERYTHING. I
ALSO THINK THAT MOST OF US WOULD
AGREE THAT REGARDLESS OF OUR
POLITICAL AFFILIATIONS LAND USE
IN THE STATE IS KIND OF BROKEN.
IT'S A REGULATORY LEGACY OF THE
NINETEENTH CENTURY AND WE'VE
MOVED IT TO THE TWENTIETH IN THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY BY HAD A
CHANCE MEASURES. ATTEMPTING TO
MAINTAIN LOCAL CONTROL BUT CURB
AGREE JUST PROJECTS ADDRESSED
THE ISSUE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND THE PROVISION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. PROTECTING
DANGEROUS SPECIES CREATING
HORSES DATEABLE CITIES SO IT
COUNTS SEQUOIA AB THIRTY TWO SB. THREE SEVENTY FIVE AS ONLY
SOME OF THOSE MEASURES. SO WE
MUST. THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
LAND JUST AS WE HAVE TODAY IS
LARGELY THE RESULT OF OVER A
CENTURY OF PROCESS SEATS WERE IN
LOCALITIES OF LOCAL AND USES AS
THEIR MAIN DOMINANT FORMS OF
SOURCES OF REVENUE. HOTEL TAXES
SALES TAXES AND SO ON OVERLAID
BY MANY DECADES OF FORMAL AND
INFORMAL SEGREGATION REDLINING
RACISM AND WHITE FLIGHT WITH
ZONING AS A WEAPON FOR
DISCRIMINATION. THE SINGLE
FAMILIES ON WAS DEVELOPED AS A
MECHANISM TO PROTECT WHITE
PEOPLE FROM PEOPLE OF COLOR. WE
WERE RELEGATED TO SEPARATE HAD
MORE DENSE NEIGHBORHOODS. GROSS
SO MANY CALIFORNIA CITIES WAS A
DIRECT RESULT OF WHITE FLIGHT
CREATING INDEPENDENT SUBURBS.
WITH THEIR OWN TAXPAYERS
SWITCHING OUT WELL OFF OF THE
OLDER URBAN CORES FOR JOBSSTILL
REMAINED AND SUPPORTED BY
SUBSIDIZED ROAD AND HIGHWAY
BUILDING. COMMUNITY COMMUTING
ONE OUT AND THE DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITY WAS MORE THAN HAPPY TO
JUMP ONTO THE BANDWAGON. GREEN-FIELDS HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
EASIER TO DEVELOP AND THE
STATE'S POST PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENT
LAWS AMONG OTHER MEASURES. WHAT
MADE IT EVEN EASIER FOR LARGE
SCALE. SUBURBAN DEVELOPERS. THIS
IS OBVIOUS. OVERSIMPLIFICATION
BUT EVEN IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
ATTEMPTS TO CURB SPRAWL FOR
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS
FOR ATTEMPTED MOSTLY TO FAIL. IN
THE END IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES WE GOT BOTH SYKORA
THAT WAS UP TO MAKE OBVIOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF
DEVELOPMENT ESPECIALLY ON THE
URBAN FRINGE AND PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN. THESE ARE ONLY
COMPOUNDED EXISTING DISTORTIONS
REWARDING STRIP MALL DEVELOPERS
AS THOSE INCREASED SALES TAXES
AS WELL AS COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL PROPERTY OWNERS-
THESE FURTHER UNDERMINED OF
MULTIPLE UNIT HOUSING
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH MIXED USE OF
THE- TYPES OF HOUSING- VARIOUS
TYPES OF HOUSING ON THE SAME
STREET ACCESS TO PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION PROVISION OF OPEN
SPACE AND MUCH MUCH MORE. I
WOULD ARGUE PRIVATIZING A GREAT
DEAL OF THE PUBLIC GROUND.
LEAVES US DEVELOPED AND CONTINUE
TO CREATE LAND AND MATERIALS
EXPERT PICKS STUDENTS OF FORMS
OF LAND DEVELOPMENT REQUIRING
MILES OF NEW ASPHALT WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY PETROLEUM. AND
PARKING LOTS CONCRETE RIBBONS OF
ROADS AND SIDEWALKS POWER LINES
PIPELINES UNDERMINING ALL BEST
ATTEMPTS TO CREATE MORE
SUSTAINABLE CITIES. SO RATHER
THAN MAKING BETTER USE OF THE
ALREADY DEVELOPED BUT OFTEN
UNDER UTILIZED URBAN FABRIC WE
MOVED UPWARD. LEAVING THOSE
AREAS BEHIND UNLESS OUR TARGETS
FOR GENTRIFICATION WHICH SIMPLY
EXACERBATES HOUSING QUALITIES IN
THIS IS BEEN GOING ON FOR HALF A
CENTURY AND IT'S EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO UNWIND. BUT IT
NEEDS TO BE UNDERSTOOD. AND
UNPACKED TO MOVE FORWARD. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ARE CAUGHT IN A BY.
THEY RELY ON LOCAL REVENUES FOR
THEIR OPERATIONS AND LOCAL
REVENUES ARE GENERATED BY LAND
USE SO THE TENT IS ON FOR
HIGHROAD STUFF MAKES SENSE BUT
IT UNDERMINES COMMUNITY
UNDERMINES CLIMATE GOALS AND
UNDERMINES AFFORDABILITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY. USABLE FINANCES
IT'S EVOLVED OVER THE DECADES
AND ESPECIALLY WITH PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN TO EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
SIX. YES STRETCHED AND BRUTAL.
SO CLIMATE CHANGE AS MORE
URGENCY TO ADDRESSING THE
SLEDGES PATTERN BUT ONE SHOULD
NOT FORGET THAT THE POOR AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE FAILED TO
SLOW VIOLENCE OF THIS SYSTEM FOR
A LONG TIME. ONLY TO EXPERIENCE
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
INDUCED HIGHER NUMBERS A FEW
DAYS AND HIGHER HEAT MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY THAN OTHERS AS
WELL AS THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
INCREASED FINANCIAL IS ATION
REALISTIC. ONE SECTOR IN MY
OPINION- BUT NOT JUST MY OPINION
I THINK IT'S AN INFORMED
OPINION- ABOUT SEEMS TO SKATE
MUCH RESPONSIBILITY AS THE
PRIVATE SECTOR NOW CHARACTERIZED
BY EVEN LARGER SCALE BUILDERS
AND EQUITY CAPITAL. IT SECTOR IT
IS OUR TIME PLAN DETERMINING
DELAY OUT OF HOW WE LIVE OUR
ABILITY TO INTERACT TO GET FROM
PLACE TO PLACE OUR ACCESS TO
OPEN SPACES AND SHOPPING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
ANCILLARY POLLUTION.
SUSTAINABILITY HAS BECOME
TRANSLATED INTO CARBON OFFSETS
SO STEPPING BACK ONE MUST ASK
WHAT KIND OF VISION FOR HOW THE
DESIGN AND BUILD THE PLACES WE
ALL LIVE IN DOES THE INDUSTRY
HALF WHAT IS THE VISION LARGELY
DRIVEN BY FINANCIAL FORMULAS FOR
PROFIT WHICH ARE NOT SMALL IF
YOU START LOOKING UP THE PROFIT
MARGINS OF LARGE SCALE
DEVELOPERS IT'S ABOUT EIGHTEEN
PERCENT. ANNUALLY AFTER ALL. HOW
CAN NEW YORK CITY EQUITY CAPITAL
REALLY CARE WHAT HAPPENS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD OTHER THAN
UNDERSTANDING THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT. WE HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT A FOR CONCERNED ABOUT
PRODUCING HOUSING FOR PEOPLE.
DECENT HOUSING PEOPLE CAN AFFORD
AND DOESN'T HAVE TO OUR CLIMATE
BURDEN THAT CREATE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES WE ARE IN A CONTEXT
WHERE LAND IS SO PRIVATELY AND
DEVELOPMENT IS LARGELY DONE BY
PRIVATE COMPANIES. IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PRODUCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON THE FUNDAMENTALS ARE
STRUCTURED AROUND EXCHANGE VALUE
OR PROFIT. THAT IS TO SAY PROFIT
CLASSICALLY THE SITUATION HAS
BEEN REFERRED TO AS THE TENSION
BETWEEN USE VALUE BEING IN A
PLACE AS A HOME AND USING IT AS
YOUR HOME AND EXCHANGE VALUE.
THE MARKET DRIVEN FORCES THAT
SHAPE OUR VIEW THAT LAND
OWNERSHIP IS A FINANCIAL ASSET.
IF OWNERSHIP IS AN ASSET THAT WE
WANT PRICES TO GO UP TO MAKE A
PROFIT. BUT IF OWNERSHIP OR
ACCESS TO HOUSING IS A HUMAN
NEED THEN THE MARKET MOTIVATIONS
FOR PROFIT ARE INCOMPATIBLE. SO
WHAT WHAT IS TO BE DONE. WE NEED
MANY MORE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS IN LAND DEVELOPMENT
FOR THE STATE TO THAT IS
GOVERNMENT WHETHER IT'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REGIONAL GOVERNMENT
STATE GOVERNMENT. CAN GUIDE THE
TYPES OF DEVELOPMENT AND RATES
OF RETURN FOR PRIVATE DEVELOPERS
THAT DRIVE DOWN COSTS AND WE
HAVE A MODEL FOR THIS KIND OF
SITUATION WITH A PRIVATE
MONOPOLY UTILITIES THEY PROVIDE
A PUBLIC SERVICE WE ENABLE THE
SHAREHOLDERS TO MAKE A PROFIT
BUT ONLY HONEST CERTAIN LEVEL.
THE STATE THAT IS AGAIN
GOVERNMENT. WHATEVER SCALE USED
TO PURCHASE LAND USING EMINENT
DOMAIN TO PROVIDE HOUSING AFTER
ALL IF WE WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TO PURCHASE LAND FOR FREEWAYS BY
EMINENT DOMAIN WE OUGHT TO BE
ABLE TO PURCHASE LAND FOR
HOUSING BY EMINENT DOMAIN I KNOW
IT'S A VERY BIG ASK BUT I ALSO
THINK IT. IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY CRITICAL. WE NEED
TO ELIMINATE THE SINGLE FAMILY
ZONES BUT DOESN'T NEED A LIMON
HANGS SINGLE FAMILY DWELLINGS BY
ANY MEANS IT JUST MEANS THE ZONE
ITSELF. IS A- NEEDS TO BE
RETHOUGHT COMPLETELY AND ALLOW
GENTLE DENSITY TO GRADUALLY
CHANGE OVER THE STERILE SINGLE
FAMILY ZONE INCLUDING AND
INCLUDING THE ABILITY TO BUILD
NEIGHBORHOOD COMMERCIAL. WITH A
VERY GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS WAS
THE RECENTLY PASSED MINNEAPOLIS
PLAN WERE IN MINNEAPOLIS THEY
LOOKED AT THEIR ZONING AND
REALIZED IT WAS A LEGACY OF
HISTORICAL RACISM AND THAT THE
SINGLE FAMILY ZONE. ENDED UP
REINFORCING PRIVILEGE TO A
DEGREE THAT WAS EXTRAORDINARY SO
THEY HAVE A THEY HAVE UNLIMITED
OF THE SINGLE FAMILIES ARE YOU
CAN STILL HAVE SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE BUT
YOU'RE ALSO ALLOWED. THIS GENTLE
DENSITY I'M THROUGHOUT THE CITY
THAT I THINK- REALLY BEGINS TO
CHANGE THE EQUATION ABOUT HOW WE
THINK OF WHERE WE LIVE AND WE
COULD HAVE. YOUR KID TO WALK TO
THE NEIGHBORHOOD GROCERY STORE
YOU CAN GET YOUR HAIR CUT OR AND
YOU HAVE MUCH BETTER ACCESS TO
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION WITH THIS
KIND OF DENSITY. I ALSO THINK
THAT- THE STATE COULD BE TO
PROVIDE LOW TO NO INTEREST LOANS
TO SINGLE FAMILY HOMEOWNERS TO
BUILD EIGHTY USE DUPLEXES AND
MORE WE NEED TO FLEXIBLE.
FINANCE SO THAT PEOPLE WHO WISH
TO HAVE VERY MODEST INCOMES CAN
STILL. REDEVELOP THEIR LANDED
INCLUDE THE EIGHTY USE A GRANNY
FLAT THE DUPLEX AND THE REST BUT
ACCESS TO FINANCING IS VERY
DIFFICULT. AND WE NEED TO
RETHINK- FINANCING IN THAT REALM
. AT THE SAME TIME OF THE STATE
IN FURTHER TRAINING IN THE
BUILDING TRADES. TO GROW THAT
SECTORS SO THEY'RE AVAILABLE FOR
MANY SKILLS AND DEVELOPMENT WE
RECENTLY BUILT IN EIGHTY YOU IN
THE BACK OF OUR DAUGHTERS OF
PROPERTY BUT TO FIND A BUILDER.
WHO IS WILLING TO TAKE ON SUCH A
SMALL PROJECT WAS VERY VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL
LOOKING FOR MUCH BIGGER
PROJECTS. AND THAT IS IN PART
BECAUSE THERE'S INSUFFICIENT
CAPACITY IN THE BUILDING TRADES
TO DO MANY MANY DIFFERENT
PROJECTS AT ONCE SO WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN UPSKILLING
PEOPLE INTO THAT. INTO THAT
SECTOR. WE AND THIS IS NOT A NEW
IDEA EITHER WE NEED TO ENFORCE
PERMANENT ONES. AHEAD TRANSFER
OF DEVELOPMENT RIGHTS. IF YOU
DRIVE AROUND MOST OF OUR
METROPOLITAN AREAS YES WE HAVE
DEAD SPRAWL BUT IT'S NOT THAT
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF LAND TO
BE DEVELOPED. IN THE EXISTING
URBAN FABRIC AS I WAS TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER. BUT WE ABSOLUTELY
NEED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF WHAT'S
ALREADY BEEN BUILT AND ADVERTISE
THAT INVESTMENT AND THAT CREATES
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE PEOPLE CAN
ENCOUNTER EACH OTHER. WE CAN
HAVE SOCIAL LIVES A WEEKEND
ACCESS PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION WE
CAN BUILD ACCESSIBLE AND SMALL
SCALE OPEN SPACES THAT ARE
DOTTED ALL AROUND. WE NEED TO
HAVE THE GOAL OF CREATING
GENEROUS AND HOSPITABLE CITIES
AND. DENSITY IS CERTAINLY A PART
OF THAT- AND WE CAN ONLY DO SO
BY LIMITING DEVELOPMENT WHERE IT
REALLY SHOULD BE GOING. NOT FAR
HIGHER FIRE RISK AND NOT MUCH
MORE THAN THAT. I ALSO THINK-
WE'VE NEGLECTED TO REQUIRE
DEVELOPERS TO INCLUDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AT THE PROPORTIONS THAT
REFLECT THE NEED NOT JUST YOU
KNOW A SMALL SET ASIDE LIKE FOUR
UNITS IN TWO HUNDRED THAT ARE
AFFORDABLE BUT ACTUALLY IT
SHOULD PROBABLY BE THE REVERSE
GIVEN THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DOCTOR I MEAN. TO- MAYBE
QUICKLY FINISH HERE THANKS MORE
POINTS YES. ALMOST THAT IN FACT
I ONLY HAVE ONE MORE POINT- AND
IS A WE SHOULD ALSO TRY TO PUSH
FOR SPLIT ROLL APPROACH TO
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN- AND THAT
WILL HELP FUND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO RELY SO
HEAVILY ON YOUR ON THE SALES
TAX. SO I THINK THESE ARE THESE
ARE NOT. UNEXPECTED KINDS OF
PROPOSALS BUT IT'S GONNA TAKE A
LOT OF POLITICAL WILL AND I KNOW
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS I KNOW YOU
ALL OF THE TRYING VERY VERY
HARD. BUT THOSE ARE MY
REFLECTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NOW IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING YOU'RE GOING TO BE
STICKING AROUND FOR THE NEXT
PANEL SO I'M GONNA ASK THAT WE
HOLD ANY QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER
THE NEXT PANEL. AND WITHOUT WILL
BRING IN- THE NEXT PANEL WHICH
IS THE ROLE OF STATE GOVERNMENT
AND BUILDING SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES- WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE ON THIS PANEL. I'M SURE NOT
AS MS ROD THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
PLANNING A COMMUNITY INVESTMENT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL. DARWIN AT MESABI
DEPT DEPUTY SECRETARY OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY IN HOUSING
COORDINATION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE TRANSPORTATION AGENCY.
MEGHAN KIRKBY AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR HOUSING POLICY
DEVELOPMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AND CRAIG SHIELDS
THE BRANCH CHIEF FOR CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY.
DEVELOPMENT AND I WANT TO IN
ADVANCE THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
GIVING US. SO MUCH OF YOUR VERY
VALUABLE TIME TODAY ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. AND WITH THAT I
WILL OPEN UP TO THE NEXT PANEL
THE NEXT SPEAKER.
AND I BELIEVE. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE CHAU HARNESS MISSOURI HAD
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY WE CAN
SEE YOUR SLIDE BUT NOT YOU OR
HEAR YOU. WITH YES WE JUST HEARD
YOU IT. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH HELLO
EVERYONE AND THIS IS CYRUS MUSES
LOOK AT THE DIRECTOR OF THAT CAN
YOU YEAH. CAN YOU MISS NOT
PLANNING FROM CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF ISSUE C. TO
INSIDE SYSTEM WILL COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. IN GENERAL AND WHAT WE
DO AS AN STATE HERE AND I WILL
STOP AND MIGHT BE EASIER TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE ARE NOT HAVING ANY
BANDWIDTH ISSUE HERE AND I'M
PASSED ON THE SLIDE I WOULD LIKE
TO GO OVER. SO I WOULD LIKE TO
GO OVER WHAT TO DO AND SHE'S N.
OKAY JOHN- WE ARE ACROSS IS JUST
HOPE YOU'RE HAVING A BRAND NEW
PROGRAM POLICY INITIATIVE. AND
TEAM OVER SHE GOAL IS TRYING
RESIDENTS MEETING ARE HAVE A SET
UP PRIORITIES LIE TO SOME.
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP. RESEARCH
AND RESIST AND AGES COURT. THESE
GOALS AND PRIORITIES HAVE THEIR
BASES IN OUR DISTINCT BUT
COMPLEMENTARY SUCH. YES YOU SEE
IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED. TO-
BASICALLY THE BUILT ON
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
AND WE HAVE THE SERVER AND
COUNCIL THAT HAS DIFFERENT
SECRETASE TO BE PART OF IT AND
OF YOUR ACCOUNT WILL CLOSE
LEGISLATORS AND OUR COUNCIL
MEMBERS. A LINE USE THE AND
PLANNING TOUCHES NEARLY EVERY
EACH OF CALIFORNIA COMPLAINING
FACING TODAY AND FARMING LAND
THIS PATTERN TO ALIGN AND
ADVANCE AND WITH CLIMATE EQUITY
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
CONCENTRATION IS A KEEP TRACK
FOR US. AND PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION PERSPECTIVE. AS
YOU CAN SEE ON THE LEFT SIDE OF
THIS- SLIGHT NON. THE SEC
OVERSEAS ACROSS SAID DESCRIBING
INCLUDING BOTH TRANSFORMATIVE
CLIMATE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
WHICH I WILL GO OVER AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INSTEAD WE
CAN USE PROGRAM WHICH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM A CD WAS A PART
AGENCIES ABOUT THE PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF. OUR SECOND A
COLLECTIVE PURITY IS PARTNERING
WITH THE AND INVESTING IN KEY
MIDEAST ACCOMPLISH BUILDING
SOCIAL INFRASTRUCTURE BY
CENTERING COMMUNITIES. IN POLICY
PLANNING PROGRAMS AND RESEARCH
BY BUILDING AUTHENTIC
RELATIONSHIPS THAT ENSURING
COMMUNITIES HAVE EQUITABLE EASY
ACCESS INVESTMENT OTHER RESOURCE
. AND BY BUILDING MEDICAL
INFRASTRUCTURES AS HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER
ESSENTIAL FEATURES STARTING TWO
WEEKS. I WOULD LIKE TO FOCUS ON
STERN TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM WHICH WAS
THE MAIN REASON THAT YOU WERE
INVITED FOR THIS- COMMITTEE
HEARING- TCC PROVIDES AN
INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY LED
TRANSFORMATION ENSURING
COMPREHENSIVE CAN WE GET
BENEFITS THROUGH PROJECTS AND
PLANS IN. REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. OKAY NOT A
DEVELOPMENT REPLACE BASEMENTS ME
DIFFERENT APPROACH IN
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES FACING IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE MOTION AND THIS INVEST.
TO SEE FUNDS CLIMBED OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
PROMOTE. HUNDREDS EVEN SEE
FALLING A ROBUST CROSS SECTORAL
COMMUNICATION AND PROCESS IF
THIS IS THE PRODUCT IS UNIQUE IN
THAT IT'S FUNDS TRANSFORM THE
PLANS. AIMED AT FOSTERING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INCREASING EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND AVOIDING
DISPLACEMENT OF PROJECT. AREA
RESIDENTS AND GUESTS. SO I WILL
TOUCH ON SOME OF THE UNIQUE
ASPECTS OF THE TCC PROGRAM WHICH
MAKES IT DIFFERENT FROM ANY
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE
PROVIDES. THE FIRST ONE IS THE
COLLABORATIVE STAKEHOLDER
DESTRUCTION. DO YOU THINK I
LINE'S REQUIRES AN OVERSIGHT
BODY COLLABORATIVE OR STRUCTURE
THAT GOVERNS HE SEEMS LIMITATION
AND CLOSE NOT ONLY PROJECT
PARTNERS BUT ALSO RESIDENTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS THE PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT TERMS ARE SUBMITTED
APPLICATION. AND AMENDED INTO
THE GRANT OF. IT'S IN MANY ONE
PARTNERSHIP TO ENSURE DESIGN
PROJECT AND- THIS IS A COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND PARTNERS WORK
TOGETHER KIND THE TIME DROPPED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO CHANNELISE
AND TRANSFORM THEIR SPACES TO
MEET CLIMATE GOALS AND BUILD
THEIR COMMUNITIES CONFERENCE.
THIS INITIALS. OF THE SMALL CAN
BE THE ORDER. THE FIRST EXAMPLE
THAT I WOULD PROVIDE IS THE
WHAT'S THE RISING LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL JUST COMPROMISED
STAKEHOLDERS FROM EACH
NEIGHBORHOOD. I DON'T DIFFERENT
REPRESENTATIVES FROM RESIDENTS
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS COMMUNITY
AND FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THESE TRUCKS WITH MEMBERS.
AND HELPING TO TROUBLESHOOT
SENSITIVE IMPLEMENTATION. ISSUES
SUCH AS PART OF. I SIXTY PLACE
THAT THERE WITH STATE TO ORDER
TO VISION OF THE APPLICATION.
PROJECT CALLED PARTNERS ALSO
FORGED A CONNECTIONS TO SHARE
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT PROJECTS
AS SIMPLE AS SHARING RESOURCE AS
FLYERS OR POOLING RESOURCES WITH
PARTNERS THEY DON'T HAVE
COLLABORATED WITH UP TO SIX. THE
OTHER EXAMPLE THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE A SPOKESMAN IN
STOCKTON THE PAST LOCAL ADVANCE
PAYMENT RESOLUTION TO ENABLE
SMALLER ORGANIZATIONS
PARTICIPATE BY ENSURING MORE
FREQUENT CASH. THE COMPONENTS
COMPONENT OF THE TCC PROGRAM IS
THAT COMMUNITY AND DESIGNED THAT
TO HIS MULTI GROUP FOR THE MONTH
OF MONTHLY BENEFIT PROJECT
PURPOSE. THIS IS THE AUTHORIZES
AUTHORIZING STATUTE AND THE
PROGRAM FRAMEWORK ASK FOR
PROJECTS TO NOT ONLY MEET GHG
REDUCTION GOALS BUT ALSO PROVIDE
ME MY MENTAL ECONOMIC AND PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFITS RENTS. THE KING
IS THE TCC DIGRESS PROGRAM
FRAMEWORK EMPOWERS COMMUNITIES
TO DESIGN PROJECTS. WITH
MULTIPLE COMMUNITIES THAT'S
WHAT'S AND COMEDIANS TAX
FLEXIBILITY TO DESIGN SUCH A
PROJECT. AND TO SEE WHAT'S ON.
THE EXAMPLE IS TRANSFER FRESNO
WILL BE HELP. LEAD US OF. KEEP
MEETING THEM SPOKE ON THIS A
PROJECT WITHOUT. WHAT THE LIVE
AND READ THEIR ARTICLE MATTERS
IN ADDITION DECREASE GREENHOUSE
GAS. AND AS YOU CAN SEE ANY OF
FONG MULTIPLE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE ESPECIALLY IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IF I'M
TRYING TO ACCESS YOUR CAR SHARES
REGIONAL TRANSIT ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE PROJECT. CAN BE
MICROGRID SOLAR ENERGY PARK
RECREATION CENTER. AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR NEXT YEAR KANEMI
ET BUS MAINTENANCE MECHANIC
MECHANIC'S SOLAR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY INSTALLATION METHOD
OF BUILDING CONSTRUCTION AND
SUSTAINABLE ACT WHICH IS LIKE A
PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE. AND THIS
IS ONLY A SMALL PORTION OF WHAT
IS FUNDED UNDER THE TWO SIX. THE
OTHER UNIQUE ELEMENT IS THE
SUBSTANTIAL AWARD AMOUNT
COMMUTING GAUGE MINT AND
TRANSFORMING LEVERAGING THE
CRIMES OF THE PROGRAM. THE TCC
MAKES SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS
RANGING BETWEEN TEN MILLION TO
SIXTY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION.
WITH IDEAL OF TWENTY TO TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR IT.
APPLICANTS MUST BRING PERCENT
LEVERAGE COMMITMENTS AND
APPLICANTS MUST DEMONSTRATE ALL
PROJECT PROPOSAL. AND WENT
THROUGH A MEANINGFUL SELECTION
PROCESS. TO SEE LOVERS
REQUIREMENTS ENCOURAGE
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT TO
DISINVEST. FOR DISINVESTMENT
AREA DURING THE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT ON TRACK THE
IMPLEMENTATION. THIS IS A
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
REQUIREMENTS EACH INSURE
SUBTLETY CCL. LEVERAGE
INVESTMENTS NEED TO COMMUNITY. A
GOOD EXAMPLE IS THEN YOU WILL
FRIENDS COMMITTEE COLLEGE CAMPUS
WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY SITED
ELSEWHERE IN FRESNO WELL
SPECIFICALLY CITED TO BE WITHIN
THAT THIS IS THE PROJECT AREA IN
SOUTHWEST FRESNO AS A RESULT OF
THE TCC COMMITTEE GAVE PROCESS.
THAT ENABLED THE PROJECT TO STAY
AND SERVE THE WEST FOR THE
COMMUNITY. THE PROJECT LEVERAGE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN TO
SEE FUNDING FOR URBAN GREENING
AND THE PROMISE THAT ADDITIONAL. SEVENTY TO EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM YOUR COLLEGE CAMPUS. THE NEXT ELEMENT THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO FOCUS ON. IS BILL. THE
TCC BILLS COMMUNICATE POSSIBLY
TO FLEXIBLE READINESS
REQUIREMENTS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- FACE. THIS IS THE
REQUIRED THREE PROJECTS TO BE
SHOVEL READY BUT A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY FOR REMAINING
PROJECTS TO MEET READINESS
WITHIN THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
GRANT TO SEE PROVIDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE DURING APPLICATION
IMPLEMENTATION PHASE AND
EXPANDING TO PROVIDE CAPACITY
BUILDING SERVICING BETWEEN
APPLICATION FACE. HE IMPACT IS
THAT THIS IS READINESS FOR ALLOW
A SPACE BROUGHT THAT EXPECT AND
SUPPORT TO BE PART OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND TO SUPERVISE
TECHNICAL SYSTEM RESOURCES TO
ENSURE PARTICIPATION UNDER SRI
SOURCE COMMUNITIES. I RESIDENTS
AND MOREOVER TO PASS A BILL. A
GOOD EXAMPLE IS WHAT'S REYES
INSIDE THIS MOVIE. APPROPRIATE
YOU RECHARGE STATION THE FIRST
YEAR OF THE GRANT. AND THEY
SUPPORTED COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND DESIGNED FOR CITING YOU
CHARGE IN THE STATION THAT
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS. FOR
EXAMPLE ENSURING STATION
CONNECTED JORDAN ON HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT RESENTING YOU.
LEVERAGE GROCERY STORE IN THERE
. THE FINAL THING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO TOUCH ON. LISTEN TO TCC
IS AN ONGOING ABOUT WHICH YES
YOU SEE HAVE BUILT IN
REQUIREMENTS FOR ONGOING TOOK
PART IN THE ELECTION OF THE
PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT. THOSE
GRANTEES AND THE STATES ARE ON
TRACK TO DELIVER ON VISION AND
MISSION OF THE TO SEE PROGRAM.
WE ASICALLY INVEST FROM THE
BEGINNING TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE DELIVERING ON THEIR END
OF PROGRAM GOALS AND WE HAVE
ECONOMIC PARTNERS TO ABOUT WITH
US ON A FREQUENT BASIS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS IN THE STATE YOU
ALSO HAVE ARE STAYING ON TRACK
TO MAKE SURE TO HAVE BEEN. WE
ARE SUPPORTING THE LOW INCOME
DISADVANTAGED. MEANS OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT I WILL.
SHE AND TIME ANY. YOU MIGHT HAVE
. BEEN YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WILL
QUESTIONS AT THE OF. PAN AND I
AM AN THANK YOU FOR STAYING ON
THE TIME I'M- WE'RE HOPING THAT
EVERYONE CAN GET THEIR COMMENTS
AND EIGHT MINUTES UNLESS YOU
HAVE SOMETHING INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO SAY. WE'LL GIVE YOU
A LITTLE MORE TIME BUT- EIGHT
MEN'S WILL GIVE US THE TIME TO
HEAR FROM EVERYBODY. NEXT WE
HAVE DARWIN MESABI FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. WELCOME AFTERNOON CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK. YES GRADES- GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIRED MANY MEMBERS
MY NAME'S ON THE SOLVING OF
DEPTH REPORT ABOUT HOW POLICY
HERE ADDS MR TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY TO TALK TO
YOU ALL- I WOULD. NEVER TIME
THIS TIME DISCUSSING BOTH THE
NEED FOR. A BUILDING SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES THE ROLE
TRANSPORTATION PLAYS IN THAT
MISSION AND WHAT KALISTO
SPECIFICALLY IS DOING TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE. AS ALL OF YOU KNOW
AND AS WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF A CLIMATE
CRISIS. AND THEREFORE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US ACROSS
GOVERNMENT TO WORK TOGETHER TO
STRENGTHEN OUR RESILIENCE IN THE
FACE OF THE INCREASING. MASON
BEER CLIMATE IMPACTS ALSO
AGGRESSIVELY BRINGING DOWN
CARBON EMISSIONS TO AVOID-
FURTHER CATASTROPHIC OUTCOMES-
AND ENTIRE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR. I NEED TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION- YOU PROBABLY HARD THE
DATA POINT BY NOW ROUGHLY HALF
OF ALL CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS COME FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. SO WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE ANY PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE- THERE
REALLY IS NO TIME TO WASTE WE
NEED TO TACKLE. THIS ISSUE NOW
NOW IT'S TWO YEARS FROM NOW OR
FIVE YEARS DOWN THE ROAD- AND
THAT'S WHY. IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AFTER TWO YEARS OF
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH AND
INVITES- CAL STAR LEASED OUR
FINAL HAS CORPORATE ACTION PLAN
FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE OR CAP DIED AS WE
CALL IT. BOB KATTER DETAILS HOW
THE STATE RECOMMENDS INVESTING
BILLIONS OF DISCRETIONARY- I
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
TO AGGRESSIVELY COMBAT AND ADAPT
TO CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE
SUPPORTING. PUBLIC HEALTH SAFETY
AND THAT COULD BE GOALS- THE
PLAN BUILDS ON GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
CLIMATE EXECUTIVE ORDERS
TARGETED AT REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION- SECTOR TO REACH
MISTER TEMPERATURES CLIMATE
GOALS- ONE OF THESE SUCH OF
THESE EXECUTIVE ORDERS IN TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT YOU MAY RECALL
REQUIRED ALL NEW CARS SOLD IN.
CALIFORNIA A LADY VEHICLES TO BE
ZERO EMISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE AND COMMERCIAL OUR TRUCKS
TO BE ZERO EMISSION BY. TWENTY
FORTY FIVE- THESE ARE IMPORTANT
IF YOU STEPS IN REDUCING
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS- BUT WE
KNOW THAT EVEN UNDER THE MOST
SIX. SENERE FOR ADOPTED.
ADOPTION OF ZERO VEHICLE. ENTER
THE ZIP TRANSITION CLEANER FUELS
THE FACT IS WE CANNOT MEET. OUR
TRANSFER RELATED CRIME GOALS FOR
RELYING. ON THE TECH. COMBUSTION
ENGINE. VEHICLES OR ON OUR FOR
TO COME AND IT CONTINUED. AND
INCREASING VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED OR VMT AT RECALL IT
GRANTS TO UNDERMINE OUR
TECHNOLOGY PROGRESS. TO MEET OUR
GOALS WE WILL NEED TO COMBINE
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY EFFORTS WITH
THE MOVE TOWARD REDUCING OUR
DEPENDENCE ON DRIVING- AND
REDUCING GUARANTEED. RAPIDLY TO
THE ACROSS OVER. YOU ALL TOOLS
ON OUR TOOL. I WHICH IS WHY
THANK ORDER AND NINETEEN WHICH
LED TO THE CREATION OF CAPT I
CALLED ON TELSTRA TO LEVERAGE
STATE TRANSPORTATION SPENDING
DOLLARS TO MEET OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS- CAMPAÑA IT'S A
HOLISTIC FRAMEWORK AND BLUEPRINT
FOR HOW WE PLAN TO PRIORITIZE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS. ANYWAY THE REDUCES
OUR DEPENDENCE ON DRIVING AND
ULTIMATELY GHGS. ENERGY MAKE IT
TURNS OUT DOESN'T STATE TO MOVE
IN A NEW DIRECTION AND MANSINGH
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION- IT'S
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE MULTIPLE
OPTIONS WHEN IT COMES TO TRAVEL
TO RESEARCH. ON THIS WEEK WITH
INCREASING ACCESS TO TRANSIT
RAIL WALKING AND BIKING. IT ALSO
MEANS CREATING A COMPETITIVE
INSIST AND SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION TRUST AGAIN
PEOPLE WHERE THEY NEED TO GO TO
TIMELY CONVENIENT SEAMLESS AND
AFFORDABLE MANNER- AND THAT
MEANS MOVING AWAY FROM OUR LONG
STANDING PRACTICE OF GIVING A
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE. TO THE
AUTOMOBILE WHEN IT COMES TO
SELECTING A FUNDING PROJECTS.
INSTEAD THE MISSIONS OF FIND
WAYS TO PRIORITIZE PROJECTS THE
GREAT HEALTHIER AND MORE
SUSTAINABLE TRAVEL CHOICES ARE
PROJECTS THAT ENCOURAGE AND
ACCOMMODATE MORE DRIVING. THE
TRADITIONAL PRACTICE OF
PRIORITIZING MOVEMENT OF
VEHICLES OVER THE MOVEMENT OF
PEOPLE HAS HAPPENED BY PROVIDING
INEQUITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HAS RESULTED IN CAR OWNERSHIP
BECOMING AN EXPENSIVE NECESSITY
FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS IN LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. TO ADDRESS ALL
THESE ISSUES AND TO MAKE IT
EASIER TO PROVIDE SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS FOR
CALIFORNIANS. WE NEED TO INCLUDE
SUSTAINABLE LAND USE DECISIONS
AND DEVELOPMENT OF SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES. WE KNOW THAT THE
BEST TRANSPORTATION SOLUTION IS
ACTUALLY- IN THE SOLUTION- SO
PROMOTING COMPACT AND FULL
DEVELOPMENT WHILE PROTECTING
RESIDENTS BUSINESSES FROM
DISPLACEMENT. WILL BE KEY IN
REDUCING OUR DEPENDENCE AND
DRIVING AND MEETING OUR CLIMATE
GOALS- WHILE THE SAME TYPE
PROTECTING NATURAL MORE MORANTZ
FROM. TO MEET MY OF USES.
CHAPTER RECOGNIZES CRITICAL LINK
BUT TRANS. AND WHAT FIRST
PROJECTS WE BILL AND WHERE WE
BUILT ON AND THE FACT THAT THAT
HAS A KEY INFLUENCE FACTORS THE
SORRY NGUYEN USES- WHILE WORKING
WITH THE EXISTING FUNDING FOR
AND BUILDING UPON ITS OF S. B.
Y. CHARACTER IT'S BEEN FOR ON
THE JUST. TRANSFER FIRST PRO
UNDER THE K. STUMP. WE'RE STILL
AGENCIES HAVE A ROLE IN SCHOOL
RECOMMEND AND SO FRAUD. THAT
WILL BE CONSTRUCTED OF THESE
PROGRAMS THE CAB DRIVER CAN BE
FOUND ON A HANDOUT THAT WAS
PROVIDED PRIOR TO THIS LET'S
HEARING- AND JUST USE THOSE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE SORT OF TEN
PRINCIPLES ALSO FOUND THAT HAND
OUT THEY CREATE THE FRAMEWORK
FOR WHAT'S CAL SURPRISE TO
PRIORITIZE WITH DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING AND HOW WE SHOULD DESIGN
THESE PROJECTS- CALTRAIN
INCLUDES SPECIFIC STRATEGIES AND
ACTIONS THAT MAKE UP THE SWEET
OF PROPOSED CHANGES. TO
STRANGERS PROTECTION PLANNING
OUR PROGRAMMING INVESTIGATION-
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE OUR GOALS-
AND THESE PROGRAMS PLANS AND
PROJECTS ARE ALREADY BEING
UPDATED TO REFLECT THESE CAPITA
PRIORITIES SINCE CAPITA OFFICERS
LAST SUMMER- SPECIFICALLY AS IT
RELATES TO PROMOTING AND FELT
CALTRAIN INCLUDES ACTIONS FOR
STATE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE A LAND USE
NEXUS ORLANDO'S CRITERIA TO
PROMOTE THE USE OF PRO HOUSING
POLICIES. THESE POLICIES
BUILDING ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT'S PRO HOUSING
DESIGNATION PROGRAM- OPENS AND
DEVISE TRANSPORTATION PROJECT
APPLICANTS AND THINKING ABOUT
THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO OUR STATE
AND LOCAL HOUSING GOALS IN
ADDITION TO INCENTIVIZING
ENVELOPES APART SAID DRESS AND
DIRECT. OUT TO ADDRESS THE
DIRECT AND INDIRECT EFFORTS-
PROJECTS CAN HAVE ON
DISPLACEMENT OF RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITY. THAT
IS WHY AFTER I ALSO INCLUDE AND
THAT TO EXPLORE WAYS. TO
INCENTIVIZE JUST STRATEGIES
WITHIN FOR- AND THIS WORK IS
UNDER. I MAY RESULT IN WRITE
COMMITTEE FOR PROGRAM. OR
STATUTORY CHANGES TELL TRANSFER
PRO COME JUST MORE- IT USED FOR
PROCESS AGENCY TO UNDERTAKE THIS
WORK IN AND- HOLD ON OUR
EXISTING PROGRAM LIKE THE FOR
WHAT I SYSTEM COMMITTEES FOR. IN
TRANSPORT I'M A COMMUNITY AND I
DON'T. I'M POWER- YOU CAN YOU
KNOW OUR ARE IN FACT DISPLAY.
FINALLY I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT I
NEW PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR
TRANSFER PACKED- A BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES AND
EQUITABLE COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA- AS YOU KNOW THE
FEDERAL BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW ALSO KNOWN
AS- BUT FOR SUCH INVESTMENT JOBS
ACT OR I HAD J. WILL BE
PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT FUNDS FOR
CALIFORNIA OVER THE COMING
YEARS. AMONG THE DISCRETIONARY
PROGRAMS THAT AYE I JANE CREATES
IS THE NEW RECONNECTION
COMMUNITIES PILOT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR REMOVING
RETROFITTING OR MITIGATING
EXISTING TRANSPORTATION
FACILITIES THAT CREATE BARRIERS
TO MOBILITY. ACCESS OR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENTS- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDES A
COMPELLING INVESTMENT TO THIS
FEDERAL PROGRAM THAT WAS FIRST
CALLED FOR AN CAP GUY. I CALLED
THE CALIFORNIA RECONNECTING
COMMUNITIES I WAS TO BOULEVARDS
PILOT PROGRAM- WHICH IF ENACTED
CAN BE USED TO LEVERAGE FUNDING
TO COMPETE FOR THIS NEW FEDERAL
DISCRETIONARY GRANT PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM COULD HELP CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A BILL FOR ONE
HOUSING AS WELL AS GREATER
CONNECTIVITY AND SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ALL
WHILE PLACING A STRONG EMPHASIS
ON ANTI DISPLACEMENT STRATEGIES.
TO ENSURE CURRENT RESIDENTS
BENEFIT FROM THOSE IMPROVEMENTS
BY WESTMARCH PROGRAM PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LIKE KEY EQUITY
AND SOCIAL MEDIA OBJECTIVES AND
BUILD UPON. THE SUCCESSES OF OUR
PROGRAMS LIKE TEACH EACH YEAR-
AS MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY- ABOUT
THE SURGICAL COUNCIL- BEES AND
EVERY. AND BUT ALSO PROGRAM. I
HAD TO SYSTEM- CAN. OUT BONTA
BROUGH CHANGE THAT ARE NAY TO
RESPOND TO CHANGE- THE TIMES
WERE IN A OBVIOUSLY. A NOTE
TRADED BY OTHERS YOU'RE TO.
CALLING AT. DIFFERENTLY ACT
DIFFERENTLY AND TRUST
INVESTMENTS THAN WE'VE DONE A
THE PAST- SO WE'RE EXCITED TO
WORK- PLEDGE AND AGENCY ON- TO
I'M NOT IMPROVE CAP BY- BUT FIND
OTHER. TO WORK TO- ON ON MAKING
CHANGES NEEDED THAT TO MEET OUR
COLLECTIVE GOAL SO ABOUT IT
WOULD FORWARD TO. DISCUSSING OUR
WORK FURTHER WITH YOU- AND- I
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP AND
THEN BACK TO SPEAK HERE TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU THERE'S A
LOT OF INFORMATION THERE I
APPRECIATE IT. OUR NEXT PANELIST
IS MET MAKING KIRKBY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING POLICY AND
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF. HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WELCOME. EIGHT ZERO.
ADAM GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER-
AND TOO MANY. AM AS THAT MY NAME
MAY KIRBY AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
FOR HOUSE POLICY. I'M ALWAYS
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING TO REDUCE
BARRIERS AND IT'S HOUSING AND
CLIMATE SMART LOCATIONS- MY
COLLEAGUE CRAIG SHIELDS WILL
FOLLOW TED DISCUSS WHAT WE USE
OUR PORTABLE HOUSING HOW WE USE
OUR PORTABLE HAVING FUNDING TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE. I'M IN
HOW WE BUILD MORE SUSTAINABLE
AND HEALTHY HOUSING I'M AND I'LL
I'M ALSO JOINED BY OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR LEGISLATION PEDRO
GO ABOUT AND OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR CODES AND STANDARDS CAL
KRAUSE WHO WILL ADDITIONALLY BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE Q. ANY PORTION
OF OUR DISCUSSION- ACDC IS AN
ABUNDANCE OF OPPORTUNITIES
REGARDING ACCELERATING INFILL
DEVELOPMENT AND RETHINKING OUR
LAND USE PATTERNS- I COULDN'T
AGREE MORE WITH YOUR FRIEDMAN.
ACCELERATING HAND INFILL HOUSING
IS GOOD CLIMATE CHANGE POLICY
AND GET EQUITY POLICY THIS MEANS
IMPROVING HOUSING POTENTIAL AND
EXISTING WILL BE A CALM MILES
TRAVELED LOCATIONS ON THESE
TRANSIT RICH AREAS OF THE STATE.
BUT IT ALSO MEANS INTENSIFYING
LAND USE PATTERNS AN INFILL
AREAS THAT MAY HAVE LESS TRANSIT
TODAY PREMIER JOBS AND
RESOURCES. THIS WILL HELP
PROMOTE INCLUSIVE COMMUNITIES
ACCESS OPPORTUNITIES REDUCE
COMMUTES INCREASED DENSITY ALL
NECESSARY STEPS AND PAVING.
ACTIVES TO ACHIEVE THIS VISION-
WHICH WE FEATURE PROMINENTLY IN
A RECENTLY RELEASED STATEWIDE
HOUSING PLAN. KEEP CALIFORNIANS
IN THEIR HOMES PRODUCE MORE
AFFORDABLE ON CLIMATE SMART
HOUSING CONTINUE TO ACT WITH
URGENCY TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING NEED. I IN THE STATE
RIGHT HOUSING PLAN WE IDENTIFY
NUMEROUS LEGISLATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGIES WE'RE TAKING TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE THROUGH
OUR HOUSING POLICY. JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES THE REGIONAL HOUSING
NEEDS ALLOCATION PROCESS FOR
THIS CYCLE ARE ARE PLANNING FOR
HOUSING NEED A WHICH ACT MY
DEPARTMENT ASSIGNS EVERY REGION
IN CALIFORNIA. TO ACCOMMODATE
WITHIN THE NEXT EIGHT YEARS WE
FOCUSED THIS PLANNING PERIOD ON
PROMOTING INFILL DEVELOPMENT AND
SOCIO ECONOMIC EQUITY THE
PRODUCTION AND THE PROTECTION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL AND AGRICULTURAL
RESOURCES. THE ENCOURAGEMENT OF
EFFICIENT DEVELOPMENT PATTERNS
JOBS HOUSING BALANCE GETTING
GETTING HOUSING WHERE THE JOBS
ARE. AND AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING- AS WELL
AS THE ACHIEVEMENT OF THE
REGION'S GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION TARGETS SO ALL OF THAT
THAT LINK THE STORY MEANS
INCREASED PLANNING CAPACITY NEAR
JOBS TRANSIT AND RESOURCES. IN A
WAY WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE. THE
LAWS ARE ALSO HELPING US. AND
DEVELOPMENT FOR MINISTERIAL
APPROVALS AND SEE QUICK ACTIONS
ALLOWING FOR FASTER DEVELOPMENT
OF HOUSING A CLIMATE SMART
LOCATIONS. WERE ALSO DOING WORK
TO EXPAND INFILL AND DENSITY
INCENTIVES TO MAKE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT AND EASIER AND MORE
ATTRACTIVE THAT WHILE AN OPTION
. THE STATE'S ALREADY RELEASED
NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN PLANNING GRANTS TO
HELP JURISDICTIONS PLANET X. BUT
I HOUSING CLIMATE SMART SMART
WAYS. AND WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL ALL AND YOUR RESOURCES
BOARD I'M PUTTING OUT SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS MORE. I
IN MORE REGIONAL PLANNING GRANTS
ALONG THESE LINES. AND I ACT SO
LUCKY TO BE JOINED BY COTTON
COLLEAGUES LIKE DARWIN AND
HONDAS- WHO REALLY- ARE WORKING
WITH ME ON THAT THESE ISSUES IN
COLLABORATION. AND DARREN
MENTIONED MANY OTHER WAYS WERE
COLLABORATING AND ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS THE SB ONE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PLANNING
GRANTS- ALL RIGHT WHERE WE WORK
WITH CALTRANS- ON REQUIRING
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
INTEGRATION. UP IT'S IT MAY
SOUND SIMPLE- BUT IT'S JUST THAT
PUBLIC POLICY WE REQUIRE
COMMUNITIES THAT ACCESS THESE
GRANTS HAVE COMPLETED THEIR
HOUSING PLANTS. IF YOU'RE GONNA
BE DOING GOOD TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING YOU NEED TO BE THINKING
ABOUT HIGHER COMMUNITIES GOING
TO GROW AND WHERE THE PEOPLE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY YOU'RE GOING TO
BE- AT DARREN MENTIONED ARE PRO
HOUSING DESIGNATION PROGRAM. AT
WHICH IS IT IS BEING EMBEDDED IN
NUMEROUS WAYS. THAT PROGRAM
REQUIRED JURISDICTIONS IN ORDER
TO EARN THAT DESIGNATION ODD TO
BE DOING DOZENS OF THINGS THAT
ENCOURAGE MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
USE PATTERNS AND REDUCTIONS IN
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED. BUT I
WANT TO SHARE THEIR WORK ISN'T
DONE HERE INFILL HOUSE FOR.
CONTINUE TO FACE FIERCE
OPPOSITION AND SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL HURDLES. IT IS NOT AS
EASY OR AS AN ATTRACTIVE OPTION
AS IT SHOULD BE TO BUILD THAT
KIND OF HOUSING WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY. IT CAN TAKE YEARS
IT CAN TAKE. MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN LEGAL DEFENSE TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN- AND THAT MEANS OUR WORK
ISN'T ISN'T DONE- WE HEAR
RESIDENTS EXPRESSED CONCERNS
ABOUT NEIGHBORHOOD CHARACTER
INCREASE TRAFFIC AND PARKING.
WHEN INFILL HOUSING WOULD
ACTUALLY HELP REDUCE TRAFFIC CUT
DOWN ON VEHICLE OWNERSHIP AND
ALLOW THOSE WHO WORKING
COMMUNITIES TO ACTUALLY AFFORD
TO LIVE THERE TOO- THE STATE IS
GOING TO USE A COMBINATION OF
CARROTS AND STICKS TO
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ACCELERATE HOUSING PRODUCTION.
IN WAYS THAT WILL ALSO HELP US
KIND CLASS COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND SEGREGATION. OVERCOMING
THESE OBSTACLES AND FILL
DEVELOPMENT IS GOING TO REQUIRE
A CHANGE FROM THE CURRENT PATH
THAT WE'RE ON. BUT THAT CHANGES
BOTH INEVITABLE AND ESSENTIAL TO
A THRIVING CALIFORNIA. NOW I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
CRAIG SHIELDS WHO IS OUR- EACH
CITY BRANCH CHIEF FOR CLIMATE
INVESTMENT- HE'LL TALK ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT INVESTMENTS IN
SEVERAL KEY PROGRAMS THAT
PROMOTE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES. THANKS MEGAN GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR FRIEDMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. JANUARY TEN GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IDENTIFIES CLIMATE CHANGE
AS ONE OF CALIFORNIA S. FIVE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES AND INCLUDES
A COMPREHENSIVE AND INTEGRATED
CLIMATE AND HOUSING APPROACH.
ALMOST EIGHT CITIES FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES CONSIDER LOCATION
AND PROXIMITY TO TRANSIT AND
AMENITIES TO SOME DEGREE WE
ADMINISTER THREE FUNDING
PROGRAMS THAT PRIORITIZE THAT
NEXUS THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM.
THE END FELLOW INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS PROGRAM AND THE TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
WELL AGENCY AND IG ARE ONGOING
PROGRAMS WITH ON GOING FUNDING
ALL THE FUNDING FOR THE G. O. D.
PROGRAM HAS BEEN AWARDED. WE HAD
A BUILDING HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE
COMMUNITIES SUPPORTS THE
REDUCTION OF GHG EMISSIONS TO
THAT END THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INVESTS ONE BILLION DOLLARS A
GENERAL FUND IN HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT THAT FURTHERS THE
STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS THROUGH
THE INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM AS WELL AS CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS AND UNLOCKING STATE
OWNED ACCESS SITES AND NON
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS FOR
HOUSING. THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
PROMOTES INFILL DEVELOPMENT BY
FINDING INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS NECESSARY FOR
BUILDING HOUSING ON INFILL SITES
INFILL DEVELOPMENT PROVIDES
BROAD ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
THAT REDUCE SPRAWL VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED. AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. SINCE ITS FIRST ROUND
OF FUNDING IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THE IG PROGRAM HAS AWARDED OVER
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
TO TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
RESIDENTIAL AND MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENTS THESE DEVELOPMENTS
WILL CREATE OVER THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND NEW AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOMES FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
OWNERSHIP PROBLEMS FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. AND
FUNDED HUNDREDS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
WERE NECESSARY AND REQUIRED FOR
THIS HOUSING. PARKS SIDEWALKS
TRANSIT LINKAGES TO WATER
SERVICE SEWER AND STREET
IMPROVEMENTS. WHAT ABOUT HOUSING
AND SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM PROVIDES FUNDING TO
PROJECTS THAT WILL ACHIEVE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
WALKING AND BIKING AND TRANSIT
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE STATE
THROUGH THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND SYSTEMIC COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
HAS INVESTED APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
HE IS ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
AWARDS FULL SUPPORT OVER SIXTEEN
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED HOUSING
UNITS. MORE THAN 92% OF WHICH
ARE AFFORDABLE. MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILES OF BIKE
LANES MORE THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED
CROSSWALKS THESE PROJECTS ARE
ESTIMATED TO REDUCE OVER FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION METRIC TONS
OF CO TWO EQUIVALENT IN MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND POUNDS THE CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANTS. THAT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF REMOVING ALMOST
ONE MILLION CARS OFF THE ROAD
FOR A YEAR. THE DEPARTMENT ALSO
WORKS TO PROMOTE SUSTAINABLE
BUILDING CODES AND STANDARDS IN
CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION HCD OVERSEES THE
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE CALGARY AND BUILDING
CODE. THE FIRST IN THE NATION
STATE MANDATED RAIN BUILDING
CODE CAL GREEN SUPPORTS TO HELP
THE RESIDENTS WHO LIVE IN NEW
HOMES YOUR MATERIAL CHOICES THAT
IMPROVE INDOOR AIR QUALITY AND
SUPPORTS OUR STATE'S GOALS OF
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND THE
REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. THE LATEST ITERATION
OF CALGARY IS FOCUSED ON
PROMOTING THE USE OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND PROVIDING GREATER
ACCESS TO EASY CHARGING IN
SEVERAL WAYS INCLUDING MANDATING
E. CHARGING STATIONS FOR NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED MULTI FAMILY.
BUILDINGS HOTELS AND MOTELS
THESE CHANGES WHICH WILL TAKE
EFFECT IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
HAVE BEEN CHARACTERIZED AS A
QUANTUM LEAP FORWARD BY MANY AND
WILL ALLOW RESIDENTS OF NEWLY
CONSTRUCTED MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHARGE THEIR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AT HOME. THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE CALTRAIN
WILL REQUIRE THAT 25230% OF
PARKING SPACES INCLUDING
CONSTRUCTED MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS INCLUDE EASY CHARGING
CAPACITY. AND THESE ARE JUST
MEMBER OF PARLIAMENT'S DOLLARS
ARE DEFINITELY ALLOWED TO GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND. THE CALGARY
MINIMUMS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
EACH CITY'S BROAD SPECTRUM OF
HOUSING AND CLIMATE INITIATIVES
WITH YOU FURTHER AND WELCOME
BACK A COLLABORATIVE APPROACH IN
IMPLEMENTING EIGHT CITIES VISION
OF CREATING SUSTAINABLE
AFFORDABLE AND EQUITABLE
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. MORE HAPPY TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS THANKS.
THANK YOU- SO THAT IS YOU ARE
THE LAST PANELIST FOR THIS PANEL
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
QUESTIONS AND I WOULD ASK IF ANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE PARTICULAR
PARTICIPATING OR WATCHING BY
ASSUME. THAT YOU FIGURE OUT HOW
TO ASK QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE
THEM. SOMEHOW I'M AB SO IN TERMS
OF QUESTIONS THOUGH FROM OUR
LIVE PANEL I'LL GO FIRST TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVY IF YOU LIKE
. THANK YOU CHAIR- I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE GREATS AND VERY
INFORMATIVE TESTIMONY FROM ALL
OUR PANELISTS TODAY. I HAD A
QUESTION FOR OUR FIRST SPEAKER
DR INSTILL- JUST YOU HAD
MENTIONED THE TENSION BETWEEN
TRYING TO DELIVER COMMUNITY-
GOODS FOR US FOR THE COMMUNITY.
AND ATTENTION THAT MOST BUILDERS
ARE DONE DOING FOR PROFIT YOU
SEE ON THE ALTERNATIVE TO
BREAKING THE DEADLOCK WITH
ATTENTION IF YOU'RE STILL ON THE
CALL. YES I'M HERE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. I
DON'T THINK THAT THERE ARE ANY
TO SOLUTIONS WITHOUT THE STATE
TAKING OWNERSHIP OF OUR- LAND
USE- AND OR- A BUILDING AND SO I
THINK THINGS LIKE EMINENT
DOMAIN. ARE REALLY IMPORTANT I
THINK THAT REDUCING THE AND
MIXED USE SO SINGLE FAMILIES ON
REALLY- IS AN AND IS NO LONGER
NECESSARY GOING INTO THE FUTURE-
AND SO I THINK THAT. THESE ARE
HARD QUESTIONS AND- WHILE I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE EFFORT
THAT'S BEING MADE TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND THESE
TARGETED PROGRAMS I THINK THAT
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS HOUSING
THAT IS SO EXPENSIVE ON THE
HIGH. AND THE EXCLUSIONARY
NATURE OF THAT HIGH END HOUSING
BECAUSE OF THESE WILL NOT
SEGREGATED NEIGHBORHOODS. THANK
YOU FOR THAT I MEAN CERTAINLY I
AM IN FAVOR OF A STRONGER STATE
INTERVENTION IN HOUSING I HAVE A
BILL RIGHT NOW ABOUT SOCIAL
HOUSING SO WE HAVE A STRONG
DIRECT EUROPEAN KIND OF ROLE. IN
THE PROVISION OF HOUSING- I DO
ALSO WANT TO ASK A QUESTION TO A
CD IF I'M ELECTED. TO CRAIG
SHIELDS AS WELL YOU TALKED A LOT
ABOUT ALL THE GREAT CREDIBLE
INVESTMENTS IN MILEAGE AND-
UNITS ARE BUILT. I THINK IN THE
HOUSING WORLD IT IS- PLAN USE
WORLD. IT IS SOMETIMES ABSTRACT
KNOWLES ALIEN FROM HUMAN LEVEL
IF WE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
SPECIFIC THINGS HAVEN'T BUILT.
SO THERE ANY SPECIFIC
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENTS THAT EACH CITY HAS
BEEN. ESPECIALLY PROUD OF THAT
WE CAN SITE OR YOU THINK OF AS
EXAMPLES OF- YOU KNOW OF A
CLIMATE SMART. HOUSING IT'S BEEN
DEALT WITH THESE GRANTS. WELL
WE'RE PROUD OF ALL OF OUR
DEVELOPMENTS OF COURSE AND IT'S
BEEN A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY TO
GET OUT AND SEE A FEW OF THEM-
D. FELL IN SAN FRANCISCO WAS ONE
SUCH PROJECT IT WAS- I DON'T
RECALL THE NUMBER OF UNITS BUT
IT'S A IT'S A GOOD SIZE-
BUILDING AND IT WAS BUILT ON
FORMER. CALTRANS LAND- PART OF
THE DAY ACROSS TOWN FREEWAYS-
ONE OF THE ON RAMP SO. WE WERE
THRILLED TO FIND THE PROJECT IN
SAN FRANCISCO THAT- PREVIOUS
GENERATIONS- OF THE DESIGN
INCLUDED DOZENS OF STRUCTURED
PARKING PLACES BY THE TIME. THIS
THIS UNIT ARE THIS BUILDING CAME
TO FRUITION THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO HAD ENDED THE
REQUIREMENT FOR PARKING SO. THAT
ENTIRE STRUCTURE- IS ARNOLD.
LIVING UNITS NO PARKING SO WE'RE
REALLY PROUD OF I WENT. WHAT WAS
THE ADDRESS THAT ONE AGAIN OUR I
BELIEVE IT'S FOR. TALENTS
HAPPENED CISCO FELL F. E. LD. AT
THE L. L. F. E. L. L. OKAY. IT'S
LIKE IN A COOL AND THEN MY LAST
QUESTION TO EXECUTIVE ALLOWED IS
YOU KNOW I HEAR A LOT FROM
NONPROFIT BUILDERS EVEN FOR
PROFIT BUILDERS THAT THEY WANT
TO OBVIOUSLY DO SOCIAL GOOD
RIGHT BUT TO BE ENVIRONMENT OR
FOR AFFORDABILITY GOALS BUT-
GOING COMPETE COMPETING IN KIND
OF A BYZANTINE GRANT PROCESS. IS
NOT ALWAYS THE MOST CONDUCIVE
SUCH FOR THEIR TIGHT TIMELINES
IN ANY DEALER PROJECTS HAVE YOU
ENCOUNTERED ANY. APPLICANTS
BEFORE LIKE THAT PROBLEM WHERE
THEY FEEL THE TIMELINE THAT
THINGS DON'T MATCH UP WITH THEIR
DELIVERY TIMELINE. WELL SURE THE
TIMELINE IS TYPICALLY ONE OF OUR
OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGES AND THE
APPLICANTS BIGGEST CHALLENGE. WE
INCENTIVIZE READINESS AND MOST
OF OUR FUNDING PROGRAMS THAT
EACH CD SO WE ASK THAT THE
DEVELOPER HAVE. EVERYTHING IS
READY TO GO AS POSSIBLE. AND
YESTERDAY AS WE MAKE THE AWARD-
WE ASK THAT THEY- BREAK GROUND
WITHIN TWO YEARS WHICH WHICH IS
SORT OF WITH AND ARE DEFINITION
OF SHOVEL READY THAT. IF THEY
CAN IF THEY CAN START TO GET
INTO YEARS ARE PRETTY GOOD
SHAPE. RIGHT AFTER THAT THIS IS
THIS MAKING HER TO BE ON THAT ON
THE POLICY SIDE IS. JUST A
REMINDER THAT WE ALSO HAVE A
ROLE IN HOW THE PRIVATE MARKET-
DEVELOPED HOUSING AND SO TOOLS
LIKE OUR HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
UNIT. ARE THERE- TO HELP SPEED
UP- HOUSING ACROSS THE SEAT
HOUSING PRODUCTION THAT ISN'T
NECESSARILY GOING THROUGH- ONE
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING
PROGRAMS. SO IF WE CAN INTERVENE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
INCREASED DENSITY CAPACITY NEAR
JOBS TRANSIT AND RESOURCES IF WE
CAN WORK WITH CITIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE APPROVAL PROCESS
THESE. ARE HAPPENING BY RIGHT
AND AREN'T EXPEDITED TIMELINE
THAT IS GOING TO SAVE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER UNIT
AND PERSONAL RESULT IN INCREASED
OF. AFFORDABILITY EVEN WHEN
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING SO THAT'S AND
THAT'S ANOTHER ROLE WE PLAY
OUTSIDE OF THE DIRECT FUNDING
AND THAT ACTUALLY IS GOING TO
INCREASE AFFORDABILITY
STATEWIDE. ABSOLUTELY TALK ABOUT
CARROTS AND STICKS THAT YOU
ACCOUNTABLE UNIT IS A GREAT
STICK I THINK TO GET MORE OF
OUR- HOUSING GOALS DONE. THAT'S
ALL THE QUESTIONS MEASURE. Q- I
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS FOR DOCTOR
CONSULT- YOU READ MADE A COMMON
ABOUT- FINDING WAYS TO.
DEVELOPMENT COSTS AND I'M
WONDERING IF THAT'S REFERRING TO
SORT OF THE OLD REDEVELOPMENT
SCHEME OR WHETHER YOU HAD
SOMETHING ELSE IN MIND I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD EXPLAIN
THAT A LITTLE BIT. OH SURE OF
COURSE I WAS REFERRING TO THE
FACT THAT. IN THE ALREADY BUILT
ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE LOTS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE WE HAVE WATER WE
HAVE POWER WE APPROACH WE HAVE
ALL OF THESE OTHER THE
TRANSPORTATION. AND IF WE'RE ARE
CONTINUING TO GO TO THE URBAN
FRENCH WE HAVE TO BUILD ALL NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE LOOK THAT
IS INTENSELY GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS- THERE'S A LOT OF
EMBEDDED GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND ALL THAT NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND IT IS A KIND
OF WASTEFUL WAY TO- TO APPROACH
DEVELOPMENT SO IN THE SENSE OF
ADVERTISING WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN
THERE- WE MAY NEED TO- IMPROVE
SOME OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
IN FACT. IT'S ALREADY THERE AND
SO WE MIGHT AS WELL USE IT
THROUGH- TO PUT YOU HAVE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES WE NEED FOR
DENSIFICATION. OKAY THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE EXPLANATION. OF
LET ME GO BACK TO ME MS KIRBY
AND MISTER SHIELDS HVE A FEW
QUESTIONS- MY QUESTION IS. I'M
WONDERING IF YOU COULD JUST TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOUR ROLE AS
A HOLDING MUNICIPALITIES
ACCOUNTABLE AND YOU MENTIONED
THE CARROT AND STICK APPROACH DO
YOU THINK THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
STICK IS IT IS IT WORKING. I
NEED BUTTON. OF MET A- I WOULD
SAY IN TERMS OF WE HAVE AN
ASPECT- YOU KNOW THAT'S FOR
MAYBE A LITTLE NEW WANTS DOES
COME IN IS WE DO- WE DO TRY TO
ASSUME THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AREN'T DOING THE
WRONG THING ON PURPOSE WE WERE
CAUGHT START FROM A FRAME OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- BUT YES WE
DO HAVE A VERY STRONG
PARTNERSHIP NOW WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND
THEIR HIGH HOUSING STRIKE FORCE
AND WE DO HAVE. WE DO HAVE THE
ABILITY- TO REALLY BRING THAT TO
BEAR- WE ARE WORKING TO INCREASE
OUR CAPACITY THERE I WILL SAY AS
WE- GET INTO THE DETAILS OF A
LOT OF THESE. I'M A LOT OF THESE
PROJECTS AND- YOU KNOW THAT-
THESE ARE COMPLICATED ISSUES- I
HAVEN'T. BUT I THINK WE LEARN
MORE EVERY TIME WE DO ONE OF
THESE AND I THINK THAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE LEARNING MORE AS
WELL- SO WE- I THINK. I THINK WE
WILL CONTINUE THIS WORK BUT AND
YOU KNOW WE TRY TO MAKE OUR- GET
OUR INBOX AND VERY PUBLIC- SO
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVING
TROUBLE GETTING PROJECTS
APPROVED CAN COME TO US- AND
HELP US WORK THROUGH THE DETAILS
WITH THEM. AND WE WERE DUE TO
WORK WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY DO NEED TO MAKE A LOT
OF- DEVELOPMENT AVAILABLE BY
RIGHT- SO THAT THE WORK CAN BE
DONE UP FRONT AND THEN PROJECT
APPROVALS CAN BE DONE AND EXPECT
IT WAY. THANK YOU AND I KNOW
THAT THERE'S TO LINK TO A POLICY
GOALS HERE AT WORK ONE IS TO
CREATE HOUSING. ND THE OTHER
ONE IS TO CREATE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES AND I KNOW THAT THE
HOUSING PIECES WHERE MOST OF THE
TALK OF THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
THE STICK COMES IN DO YOU ALSO
USE THAT FOR THE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY SIDE IN OTHER WORDS
HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT ABOUT.
ENFORCING ON COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE SPRAWLING OR ENFORCING-
SOMEHOW WE'RE TALKING TO
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T ALLOW
COMMERCIAL ANYWHERE IN THE
RESIDENTIAL AND- I DON'T GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITIES TO.
THERE ARE NOT TAKING SERIOUSLY
FOR INSTANCE THE GOAL OF
REDUCING VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
. ABSOLUTELY I THINK I THINK FOR
US SOMETIMES WILL USE DIFFERENT
LANGUAGE BUT BE ACCOMPLISHING
THE GOAL SAME GOAL- ONE OF OURCORE TENETS IS AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING AND
THAT'S ABOUT OPENING UP ACCESS
TO COMMUNITIES WHICH MEANS-
ENSURING THAT THERE ARE MULTIPLE
I WILL MULTIPLE KINDS OF HOUSING
TYPES. NEAR THE NEAR JOBS NEAR
TRANSIT YOUR RESOURCE SAYS SO
EVERY SINGLE JURISDICTION THE
STATE IS IN SOME. SOME PORTION
OF THEIR HOUSING PLAN
PREPARATION WITH US AND THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE THINGS THAT NEED
TO BE SHOWING US AS PART OF
THEIR I WOULD BUT THAT'S FOR
KIDS. THAT HAVE TRANSIT OR HAVE
THE JOBS BUT DO YOU EVER THINK
ABOUT THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
THOSE BEDROOM COMMUNITIES THAT A
SO INSTEAD OF. ASKING THE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THE
TRANSIT TO ADD MORE HOUSING DO
YOU EVER ASK THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE ALL SINGLE FAMILY TO
MOVE COMMERCIAL INTO THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
AND THAT WAY. NOT NOT THAT WAY
SPECIFICALLY I'LL SAY. I'LL SAY
THE WAY THAT WE GO ABOUT THAT
IS- AND WHAT IT WAS YOU CAN SEE
OUR WORK IN THAT AREA. IS WHEN
YOU LOOK AT WHERE THE HOUSING
NEED GOALS WERE SET. AND THEY
ARE STEP BY OUR EXPECTED GROWTH
PATTERNS BUT ALSO LOOKING AT
THINGS LIKE PENT UP DEMAND
INCLUDING VACANCY. LOW VACANCY
RATES HI OVERCROWDING RATES IT'S
ADDRESS THERE ARE WORLD
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEIR HOUSING
NEEDS WENT DOWN SUBSTANTIALLY SO
YOU KNOW PLACES LIKE ALPINE
COUNTY. I GOT THE MINIMUM
HOUSING GOAL THEY CAN GET WHICH
IS TO FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTY OVER
THE NEXT EIGHT YEARS. SO WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT INCREASING GROWTH
EVERYWHERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INCREASING BREATH WHERE IT'S
NEEDED- BUT- ALL STATE. HOUSING
I HOUSING IS NEEDED EVERYWHERE
IT'S ABOUT- CREATING A SITUATION
WHERE IT ISN'T ACTUALLY HARDER
TO BUILD AND SELL. AND THEN TO
BUILD OTHER TYPES OF HOUSING AND
I WOULD SAY THAT COMMUNITY
OPPOSITION REALLY PREVENTS THAT
FROM BEING TRUE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
BACK ON THE HOUSING DISCUSSION
BUT GOING BACK AGAIN TO THE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
DISCUSSION IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
CREATING HOUSING RIGHT IT'S ALSO
ABOUT CREATING. WAYS OF REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IN AREAS
MAYBE THAT ARE EVEN MORE BUILT
OUT. BUT IF ALSO THAT
RECOGNITION IS THAT BECAUSE OF
AN EQUITABLE DEVELOPMENT
PATTERNS YOU HAVE SOME AREAS
SOME OF OUR- LESS ARE MORE AT
CHALLENGED AREAS OR TYPICALLY
UNDERINVESTED AREAS. THAT HAVE
BORNE THE BRUNT OF MORE DENSITY
AND MORE DEVELOPMENT OVER THE
YEARS. THEY ALSO TEND TO BE THE
AREA SET UP THE TRANSIT IN THE
JOBS OFTEN. SO IT SEEMS LIKE WE
STILL CAN OUR CONTINUING IT'S
NOT A BAD THING BUT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO TRY TO OPEN UP
MORE OPPORTUNITIES IN THOSE
AREAS FOR EVEN MORE HOUSING. BUT
IN SOME WAYS THE AREAS THAT FOR
A LOT OF THOSE REASONS THAT WAS
CITED BY THE PROFESSOR AND THE
FIRST PANEL. DIDN'T DO THAT KIND
OF DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO BE THE EXCLUSIVE
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS.%
YEAH WE ARE NOT ASKING THEM TO
BECOME MORE SUSTAINABLE FOR
INSTANCE BY ALLOWING MORE.
COMMERCIAL USES IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS ONES THAT WERE DO
SO VEHICLE MILES. YOU KNOW THE
GROCER THE LITTLE BODEGAS. DAY
CARE CENTERS ALL OF THOSE USES
THAT WOULD. KEEP PEOPLE FROM
HAVING TO THEN TRAVEL INTO THOSE
DENSER AREAS RIGHT. SO DOES IT
DO YOU LOOK AT WAYS OF TRYING
TO. CHANGE THE WAY THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE PLANNING TO
ALLOW THAT ARE YOU ACTIVELY
INVOLVED YEAH THAT SPACE TO. YES
AND I DID MISUNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION FIRST SO I APOLOGIZE
BUT YES THAT IS THE OTHER COURT
SIDE OF OUR COIN AND THAT IS
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AS PART OF
OUR HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS THIS
TIME SO ALL OF THOSE
JURISDICTIONS YOU'RE SPEAKING UP
WOULD NEED TO TALK TO US ABOUT
THEIR PLACE BASED STRATEGIES-
THAT THEY- THAT THEY ARE DOING
IN THOSE TYPES OF COMMUNITIES TO
INCREASE THAT- INCREASE THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT INCREASE
THE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- AN
ACCOMPLISHMENT OF THOSE GOALS
YOU'RE SPEAKING TOO SO IT'S NOT.
ALWAYS GOING TO BE HOUSING
SOLUTIONS IT'S ALSO GOING TO BE
A MATCH A MATCH COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY
THAT'S APPROPRIATE TO THE PLACE
WERE WERE EVALUATING I'D LIKE TO
AYE THAT'S GREAT I'M GLAD TO
HEAR IT AND I'D LOVE TO SEE HOW
YOU'RE ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISHING
THAT. AND HOW YOU'RE MEASURING
THAT AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
COMMUNITIES- THE COME IN EITHER
WITH THEIR UPDATED HOUSING
ELEMENT OR THEY DON'T AND JUST
HOW YOU DO THAT BECAUSE I
REPRESENT A LOT OF BEDROOM
COMMUNITIES AND I HAVEN'T SEEN
ANY MOVEMENT AT ALL TOWARDS ANY
OF THAT LIKE NONE. SO I'M
CURIOUS AS TO HOW YOUR YOU KNOW
I HAVE TO TELL ME NOW BUT KIND
OF WHAT YOUR PARENTS ARE FOR
TRYING TO- CHANGE THAT. I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE CONNECTING
COMMUNITIES IN THE HIGHWAYS TO
BOULEVARDS PROGRAMS AND IT GOES
A LITTLE BIT BACK TO THAT EQUITY
PIECE ABOUT HOW YOU REACH OUT-
SPECIFICALLY TO. MUNICIPALITIES
AND NGOS AND PARTICULARLY TO
UNDER SIR ARE YOU KNOW
TRADITIONALLY DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND LET THEM KNOW
ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES TO APPLY FOR
THESE GRANTS AND WHETHER YOU
HELP THEM- MAKE THOSE
APPLICATIONS SO THAT THEY CAN.
HOPEFULLY BRING HOME. SOME OF
THAT FUNDING TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. GREAT QUESTION CARE
AND YOU KNOW THAT THE- I'LL
START RIGT I MEAN WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO ON THAT FRONT
HOWEVER YOU KNOW I THINK
THERE'S- THERE'S A LOT OF
GROUNDWORK AND PRESIDENT PARTY
SAID THAT WE CAN BUILD OFF OF
PARTICULARLY LOOKING AT THE
WORK. BUT AS CHEESY AS BEEN ABLE
TO DO ON THE TRANSPORT OF CLAMOR
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM- THAT THAT
HAS- CRITICS. ARE GROUND UP
APPROACHED AND DEMANDED HER
APPROACH TO THE- PROGRAM CHEN IS
PROJECTS THAT ARE- COME OUT OF
THAT PROGRAM WE'RE GOING TO BE
LOOKING TO A LOT OF THEIR BEST
PRACTICES. AS WE BUILD AS WE
BUILD THIS PROGRAM EVEN THOUGH%
IT HAS A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT NAME
I THINK IT WILL REQUIRE THE SAME
TYPE OF. ART YOUR POINT KIND OF
COMMUNITY DRIVEN- APPROACH THAT
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF. YOU
KNOW TECHNICAL SYSTEMS WORK AND
- I CAPACITY BUILDING WORK THAT
THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM AND BUILD
BUILD OFF OF THEIR- BUT YOU KNOW
IT'S A- IT'S WORK THAT WE'VE
ALSO DONE- AT. CAL STARTED
THROUGH CALTRANS OF PROGRAMS
LIKE THE TRANS INTERCITY RAIL
CAPITAL PROGRAM SO WE HAVE SOME-
EXISTING EXPERTISE ON THOSE
FRONTS BUT- IT WILL BE. A MUCH.
BIGGER AND YOU UNDERTAKEN FOR
US. THANK HAVE A QUESTION FOR-
WHICH IS HOW CALLOUS TO. INSURE
TRADE. IN DECISIONS ALIGN WITH
THE GOALS OF CAP T<c.cyan> AND THE</c>
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY HOW YOU
MEASURE THAT AND I'M GOING TO
ASK ACTUALLY EVERYBODY AFTER
THIS A QUESTION ABOUT METRICS
AND- MEASURING SUCCESS AND
EVALUATING- THESE GOALS. AGAINST
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING OUT
THERE IN IN ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY
SO I'LL START. WITH KALISTO AND
ASK ABOUT THAT. GREAT GREAT
QUESTION AND YOU KNOW SO PART
OF- CAPPED ISLAND WHAT WE
COMMITTED TO IN THE PLAN CAME
OUT WAS THAT WE WOULD BE PUTTING
OUT AN ANNUAL REPORTS WHICH IS
DUE OUT THIS FALL- ON OUR-
IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS AND HOW
FAR. WE'VE GOTTEN AND I WILL
BOTH ALSO YOU KNOW- LOOK AT
BOTH. A SPECIFIC ACTIONS AND
WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
BUT ALSO INCLUDE METRICS AND
MEASUREMENT OVERALL HOW OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE BEING
INFLUENCED. BY THIS FRAMEWORK SO
WE DO PLAN TO- YOU KNOW MEASURE
THINGS LIKE- IN A VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED AND GIGI OUTLETS FOR
PROJECTS AMONGST OTHER METRICS
FOR. INVESTMENT SUITE- THAT WAS
INCLUDED UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
CAP DIED A YEAR OVER YEAR TO SEE
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE AND SO
THAT'S SOMETHING WE COMMITTED TO
THAT. THE STAKEHOLDERS. AND BE
PART OF OUR REPORT THIS FALL.
THANK YOU AND YOU KNOW IT THE-
PUSH TOWARDS BUILDING EFFICIENCY
AND- I AM VERY GLAD THAT SOMEONE
BROUGHT UP- CAL GREEN- WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT AND VERY
IMPACTFUL- AND OF COURSE
ELECTRIFICATION OF VEHICLES IS A
HUGE PART OF OUR CLIMATE
STRATEGY. AND AT THE SAME TIME
WE CAN'T FORGET THAT REDUCING
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED IS ALSO
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS WAS
MENTIONED- THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT SUPPORTS SINGLE PASSENGER
VEHICLES IS NOT ONLY NOT
SUSTAINABLE AND LEAD TO A LOT OF
BAD PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES IN A
LOT OF TIME SPENT IN TRAFFIC.
IT'S ALSO THE REASON IS WAS ALSO
POINTED OUT THAT EVERYBODY
DOESN'T WANT DEVELOPMENT IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES BECAUSE OF THE
TRAFFIC IN THE CARS SO YOU KNOW
IN SOME WAYS ALL OF THE GREEN
CAR INFRASTRUCTURE WERE DOING.
IS A LITTLE BIT AT ODDS WITH
THEIR GOALS TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING AND TO HAVE MORE LIVABLE
COMMUNITIES IN A FIFTEEN MINUTE
CITIES SO I'M ALSO WONDERING HOW
WE EVALUATE THOSE INVESTMENTS
AGAINST OUR GOALS OF. SHIFTING
PEOPLE OVER TO MORE SUSTAINABLE
MODES OF TRANSPORTATION AND MORE
MORE SUSTAINABLE CITIES SO I
DON'T REMEMBER IF IT WAS YOU OR
MISTER SHIELDS WHO TALKED ABOUT
THOSE- ELECTRIC VEHICLE-
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS WHAT
I'M WONDERING I GUESS FOR BOTH
OF YOU HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
BALANCE. THAT GOAL WITH THE GOAL
OF NOT HAVING PEOPLE ON SO MANY
CARS. GREG ABBOTT THAT MAY HAVE
BEEN YOU KNOW BROUGHT BROUGHT
THE- YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO. WELL
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE THE ONE
WHO'S MORE GERMANE TO
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS. SURE
HAPPENED A NUMBER IN AND THEN-
IF CREDIT RATING ADEQUATE- ON ON
OUR END I THINK- YOU KNOW IT. IT
IT. WE DN'T NECESSARILY SEE IT
AS AS AS A COMPETING INTERESTS
IT'S BECAUSE- BOTH CAN BE
PURSUED ONLY AND APPARENTLY
WITHOUT HAVING. NEGATIVE
IMPACTS- ON ON EACH OTHER YOU
KNOW I THINK- THE REALITIES WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD FOR DECADES TO COME SO THE
PUSH TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE ARE
AS CLEAN AS POSSIBLE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE IMPORTANT HOWEVER
YOU KNOW WE- AT CALS AND
STRESSED THAT IT THAT IT- THEY
NEED FOR SHIFTING OF MODES IN. A
MONTH SO WE TRAVEL AND REDUCING
OUR DEPENDENCE ON DRIVING NEEDS
TO BE NEEDS TO BE A CENTRAL PART
OF THE CONVERSATION- S. MEMBER
STATION WHAT DO YOU HOW DO THAT
TRANSLATE THAT INTO ACTUAL
INVESTMENTS. HOW DO YOU
WONDERING HOW YOU BALANCE ALL OF
THAT. YEAH I THINK I THINK WHAT
MAKES ITS- FRANKLY LITTLE EASIER
ON OUR END IS THAT THE DOLLARS
MINUTES VETS- GO TOWARDS. THEY
WERE SERVING ONE PERSON I'M
SURE- ADDS A KIND OF A
TRADITIONAL TRNSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TEND TO COME FROM
DIFFEENT SOURCES SO YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE AS MUCH OF A DIRECT
KIND OF DATED A COMPETING- AT
INTEREST IF YOU WILL IN TERMS OF
A DECIDING UPON WHAT TYPE OF
PROJECT OR OVER ANOTHER GROUP
FROM A KIND OF A- ACTED WILL.
HOW YOU KNOW IT- IN THINGS LIKE
- ARE FOR EXAMPLE- WHERE WE KNOW
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
REDUCE- VEHICLE TRAVEL AND THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY ISN'T- EIGHT
GOAL THAT THAT WE NEED TO. TO
HAVE GIVEN THE IMPORTS OF RATES-
MOVEMENT OF THE STATE BECOMES
INCREDIBLY CRITICAL TO MAKE THAT
BRIGHT IT'S CLEAN AS POSSIBLE SO
THEN THAT THAT IN THOSE
INSTANCES. THE BUT I KIND OF
THEIR MISSION- VEHICLE COMPONENT
OF THE PROJECT- BECOMES KIND OF
THE CENTRAL POINT OF WHAT WE
LOOK FOR- BUT ANOTHER ALL OTHER
CASES YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE REALLY
INTERESTED IN- IS- THE MONSTER
AND ARE PROJECTS AND THEN WE YOU
KNOW ARE ENCOURAGING WORK WHERE
IT'S A PROGRAM FOR APPLICANTS TO
LEVERAGE- OTHER DOLLARS FOR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE- EFFORTS AND-
MOST OF THOSE DOLLARS DON'T
DIRECTLY COME FROM
TRANSPORTATION. INFRASTRUCTURE
OF SOURCES ALTHOUGH THERE ARE A
SMALL AMOUNT OF FUNDS THAT THE
DEAL OKAY THANK YOU SEE IF
MISTER SHIELDS OR MR KIRBY. YES
I AM. OKAY TO STANDARDS DEPUTY
COME ACROSS IS HERE AND I THINK
HE CAN. SPEAK TO ARE YOU
CHARGING. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
FRIEDMAN BECAUSE KRAUS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR INSTEAD. I'M SAY-
DURING OUR PUBLIC. FOR BUILDINGS
. THE LAST CYCLE THERE WAS THE-
AN OUTCRY FOR BETTER ACCESS TV
CHARGING AND THESE ARE
RELATIVELY LOW COST. I AM VERY
COST EFFECTIVE INVESTMENTS IN
EVEY CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT ACTUALLY ALLOWS. RESIDENT
THE MULTI FAMILY DWELLING TO
PLUG IN THEIR ELECTRIC VEHICLE
THAN PART AND THIS IS AN EQUITY
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED TO US
THAT. YOU KNOW NOT ONLY PEOPLE-
IN MUNICIPAL AREAS- NEED ACCESS
TV CHARGING BUT ALSO THOSE THAT
DO LIVE. IN MORE RURAL AREAS AND
HAVE A LONGER DRIVE TIMES THAN
THAT AND THE FACT THAT THEY
NEEDED ACCESS TO THE- TV
CHARGING. SERVICES SO THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY PURCHASE AND OWN
AND DRIVE AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
SO- WE'VE RESPONDED TO THAT- IN
PROPOSED SUCCESSFULLY- ADDING
SIGNIFICANT. ACCESS TO EACH
ARTICLE BY ADDING. 25% OF THE
AMERICAN PRESIDENT OF THE
PARLIAMENT. WOULD HAVE MANPOWER
LETTER TO RECEPTACLES. APPROVED
BY THE COURT PLAN IMPROVE AND
THEN I SAW A FIVE PERCENT-
PROVIDER PROJECTS WOULD HAVE.
HIGH POWER LEVEL TO TRY TO GET
IT. INSTALLED AND AVAILABLE FOR
RETIRED. WHETHER OR NOT THE.
CONFERENCE AND I WOULD YOU I TO
KYLE'S COM THAT FUNDING PROGRAMS
THAT I JUST CRIED. WELL FINE OUT
YOU TO CHARGE INTEREST. OKAY.
THANKS NOW AGAIN LET ME ASK ALL
OF YOU WHOEVER WANTS TO ANSWER
ABOUT METRICS TO EVALUATE THESE
INVESTMENTS IN THESE PROGRAMS-
BUT WHAT DO YOU PLAN TO HAVE IN
PLACE AND HOW CAN YOU EVALUATE
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL AND SO THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE TO SORT OF REPLICATE
THEM WERE TO YOU KNOW CONTINUE
FINDING WHERE TO CUT BACK ON
FUNDING- BECAUSE I THINK YOU
KNOW DOZEN GOVERNMENT IN GENERAL
AND I'M NOT TALKING TO YOU I
MEAN ALL OF US WHO COME FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIND THAT A LOT
OF TIME SOMETHING SEEMS REALLY
OBVIOUS AND YOU PUT MONEY INTO
IT BUT- GOING BACK AND FINDING
OUT WHETHER IT REALLY. ACHIEVE
YOUR GOALS- IS DIFFICULT FOR
INSTANCE WE MIGHT ACHIEVE THE
GOAL OF HAVING A LOT OF AB
CHARGERS OUT THERE BUT DO WE
KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE BEING USED-
DO WE KNOW THAT- OUR INVESTMENTS
IN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION AND ARE
BEING USED AND IF NOT WHY NOT SO
HOW HOW ARE YOU PLANNING TO GO
AND EVALUATE THESE PROGRAMS SO
THAT WE SPEND EVERY DOLLAR
WISELY WHICH THE PUBLIC HAS A
RIGHT TO EXPECT AND SO THAT WE
KNOW THAT WE'RE ACHIEVING THE
GOALS THAT WE SET OUT TO ACHIEVE
. HE CHECKED FRIEDMAN THIS IS
THOMAS FROM CALIFORNIA CITIES
ACROSS COUNCIL AT. THE COUNCIL
HAS A MANDATE TO PILOT THE NEW
AND INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO OFFER AND-
WHICH WE HAD EMAIL WE SHOULDN'T
TO THE TCC. MIGHT BE HELPFUL.
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE DESIGN
OF THE- WE INCLUDE THAT YOU
FOLLOW SHOULD AS A PART THE
MAGIC PART OF THE- PROGRAM.
WHICH IS REQUIRED ALL THE
APPLICATIONS TO SEPT THE SOME
DOLLAR AMOUNT FORTY PROBABLY
SHOULD DROP THEY TIRED AND
GRUMPY. AND WE HAVE PARTNERED
WITH THE LOSS CAN CENTERS TO
DESIGN AND YEAH YOU SHALL SET OF
METRICS THAT'S WILL BE TRACKED
ACROSS ALL THE INVESTMENTS THAT
WE PROVIDE. AND WE ALSO PARTNER
WITH THIS RESEARCH ENTITIES TO
MEASURE NOT THE WORSE IS THAT
ANY CONTROL CYCLE YOUR BODY THAT
YOU CAN SEE PROGRESS NOTES ARE
REALLY HAVING AN IMPACT.
THROUGHOUT THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
THIS PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
RESEARCH ENTITIES THAT WE HAVE.
NOTICED A LOT OF THINGS OF
QUESTIONS IN THE PROGRAM AND WE
HAVE UPDATED OUR GUIDANCE
REFLECTS DOES IT NOT ONLY
INCLUDES THE- REQUIREMENTS OF
OUR GUIDELINES BUT ALSO HOW
AUSTIN'S IN THE STATE
APPROACHING THE SLAB.
INVESTMENTS AND. HOW WE CAN
BETTER PROVIDE SERVICES TO. OUR
RESIDENTS AND CAL. IT HAS BEEN.
THE SUCCESSFUL PARTNERS THAT
COULD IS THE AND THE US BE
PROVIDED BETTER SERVICE THAN-
THAT'S CAN TO DO THAT BECAUSE
PRO OF ITS YOU SEE. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE WANT TO WAS A GREAT
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WANT TO
GIVE IT A TRY. I CAN I CANGO
QUICKLY A COUPLE FOR US THAT ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT AND THE LAND
YOU SIDE- ONE IS WE NOW ON THIS
FOR THE FIRST TIME THIS CYCLE.
I'M JURISDICTIONS HAVE TO
PROVIDE US THEIR ZONING IN A
STANDARDIZED FORMAT SO WE'LL BE
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. I'M TO MAP ALL
OF THE ZONING BETS I'M DONE AS
PART OF THE HOUSING PLANNING
PROCESS. I'M AND- I'M
JURISDICTIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE THAT DOWNING WITHIN
THREE YEARS OF THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT DUE DATE FOR LATER
SECTIONS THEY NEED TO COMPLETE
THAT'S OWNING. I'M BY-
JURISDICTIONS THEY DIDN'T FINISH
THE HOUSING ELEMENT ON TIME ONLY
HAVE A YEAR TO COMPLETE THAT
ZONING SO WE SPEED UP THE
ZONING- AS THEY'RE SORT OF
CONSEQUENCE FOR BEING LATE. I'M
SO WILL BE ABLE TO SEE HOW MUCH
BACK DOWNING IS FOR EXAMPLE IN
EXISTING LOW EMT COMMUNITIES OR
NEAR TRANSIT- BUT ALSO IN- KIND
JOB. CENTERED PLACES I'M LOOKING
AT THAT IDEA WAS TALKING ABOUT
OF INTENSIFYING LAND USE NEAR
JOBS NOT JUST NEAR TRANSIT- SO
THAT THAT'S A PIECE OF IT AND
THEN EVERY SINGLE JURISDICTION
NEEDS TO PROVIDE. I'M PROGRAMS
WITH METRICS- AGAIN TO EAT BOTH
THE INCREASING INCLUSIVE
COMMUNITY SIDE AND THE PLACE
BASED STRATEGY SIDE THAT'S THE
KEY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT SITES
OUT. EACH JURISDICTION HAS A SET
OF- PROGRAMS THAT WE MONITOR
AGAINS I'M AND SO WE'LL BE
LOOKING AT THOSE INDIVIDUAL
METRICS AND TIMELINES. I'M
THROUGH OUR HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY UNIT TO ENSURE
THAT- JURISDICTION- CIRCLED INTO
THAT CONTRACT. COMMITMENT WITHIN
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT. HE YOU.
SO THERE'S NO MORE QUESTIONS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR LAST
PANEL- WHICH IS GOING TO TALK
ABOUT NEXT STEPS AND METRICS
FIRST WE HAVE ANY WAITING FOR
THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
CAPPASITY BUILDING AT THE GREEN
LIGHTING INSTITUTE AND
ANTOINETTE MAYOR SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF REGIONAL PLANNING FROM SANDAG
AND SAN DIEGO WELCOME TO BOTH OF
YOU AND THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU GIVE ME ONE SECOND I'M
TRYING TO SHARE MY SLICE- CAN
SEE HERE. SURE THAT. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
EMMY WINNING THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF CAPACITY BUILDING
WITH THE GREEN THEN IT'S A TWO
WE ARE A RACIAL JUSTICE POLICY
ADVOCACY AND RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION OUT WORKING TO INTO
THE LEGACY OF REDLINING AND I
WOULD SAY OVER THE PAST DECADE
MY ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN ENGAGED
AROUND CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
POLICIES I'M REALLY ADVOCATING
TO ENSURE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS ARE POSSIBLE TO AND
MEETING THE NEEDS OF OUR MOST
TENDER RESEARCH COMMUNITIES. AND
WE ALSO HAVE TO DESIGN POLICIES
AND THAT CENTER COMMUNITIES AND
DECISION MAKING SO THE TCC
PROGRAM THAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING
ABOUT- WEEK WAS SPONSORED AB
TWENTY SEVENTY TWO AS WELL AS
THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATES PROGRAM WHICH IS A
NEW PROGRAM FOCUSED ON CAPACITY
BUILDING FOR FRONTLINE%
COMMUNITIES I'M IN THINKING
ABOUT SUSTAINABLE COUPLE
COMMUNITIES I REALLY WANT TO
HONE IN ON THE COMMUNITIES
PIECE- AND THE NEED TO CENTER
POLICYMAKING AROUND IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES
SHIPS OUT IN THIS PRESENTATION
I'M GONNA BE TALKING OF THE NEED
TO BUILD SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
FROM THE TOP DOWN. FROM THE
BOTTOM UP AND THEN ALSO.
EQUITABLE EVALUATION- SO- IF YOU
JUST TO BROWN AS A BIT I THINK
WE'VE HEARD OF THE BIT OF. THE
HISTORY AND CREDIT PRACTICES
THAT I'VE CAN. TO REDLINING
RESIDENTIAL SEGREGATION ON
INEQUITABLE OUTCOMES. AT THE
STATE NOW HAS A RESPONSE AND
WE'LL- RESPONSIBILITY TO WIELD
ITS POWER IN THE INTERACTION OF
CORRECTING INJUSTICES. SO I'VE
THREE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THREE
COULD NOT PATHWAYS HERE. NUMBER
ONE IS TO BUILD A PATHWAY FROM
COMMUNITY PLANNING TO
TRANSFORMATIVE IMPLEMENTATION.
I'M FROM THE TOP DOWN THE STATE
MUST CHANGE AT ACROSS THE BOARD.
COMMUNITIES NEED FUNDED TIME TO
ESTABLISH SHARED VISIONS DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIPS IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
PRIORITIES AND- PURSUE PROJECTS.
SO WE VERY MUCH ENCOURAGE THE
STATE TO INTEGRATE PLANNING
GRANTS ALONG WITH. THOSE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS. AND THEN THOSE
THOSE PLANNING RESOURCES HAVE TO
BE PAIRED WITH THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND FOR COMMUNITIES TO
RECEIVE AT TO. FORWARD IN
ADVANCE THERE- TRANSFORMATIVE
VISIONS RIGHT COUNTERING DECADES
OF DISINVESTMENT. ON AND
ASSISTANCE REQUIRE THAT WE MAKE
PRETTY LARGE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS. IN OUR MOST UNDER
RESEARCH COMMUNITIES IN WAYS
THAT ARE GOVERNED BY THOSE
COMMUNITIES. NUMBER TWO IS TO
TREAT COMMITTEES A HOLE INTO
MAXIMIZING THE BENEFITS. SO
COMMUNITIES NEED FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF UNIFIED PLANS
THAT CAN REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS
AND PROVIDE MEANINGFUL PUBLIC
HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIO
ECONOMIC BENEFITS. THIS REALLY
LOOKS LIKE BOTTLING INVESTMENT
TYPES- IN MUCH THE WAY THAT THE
TCC THE TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM DOES. I'M SO
THEY WERE REALLY RESPONDING TO
HOLISTIC COMMUNITY VISION AS
OPPOSED TO A MIX OF UNPLUGGING
IT INVESTMENTS THAT COME FROM
VARIOUS DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS
ALL OVER THE PLACE. AND THE
NUMBER THREE IS TO REMOVE
FUNDING AND ADMINISTRATIVE
BARRIERS- PROGRESSIVE POLICY IN
PROGRAM DESIGN ON ITS OWN IS NOT
ENOUGH. WE ALSO REALLY NEED TO
REFORM THE INTERNAL
ADMINISTRATING FINANCING AND
CONTRACTING PRACTICES. THAT
CURRENTLY ARE SERVING ISRAEL
BARRIERS AND SOUND PREVENTING
COMMUNITIES FROM ENGAGING WITH
STATE. INVESTMENT SOURCES AND A
PBLIC POLICY. SO KEEP KIND OF
EXAMPLE RECOMMENDATION THAT. I
THINK IT'S COMING UP AND FOR A
LOT OF COMMUTER D. AS IN THE
NEED TO. THE PAYMENT OF GRANT
FROM SOME STATE ARE JUST AND
REMEMBER BASE. ON WHICH WE
PRESENTS A CASH FLOW CHALLENGE
FOR NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND EVEN SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
MOST NONPROFITS AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS SIMPLY DO
NOT HAVE A CASH FLOW TO SUSTAIN
MULTIPLE MODES. OF OVERHEAD IN
PAYROLL AND BEFORE GETTING
REIMBURSED FOR. WORK AND STATE
FUNDED PROJECTS TO REALLY URGING
THE STATE TO PERMIT ADVANCE
PAYMENT OF GRANT FUNDS- AND ALSO
THINGS LIKE COMMUNICATION
EXPENSES WHICH OFTEN ARE NOT
PERMITTED. UNDER A LOT OF STATE
PRINCE. AND THEN MOVE FROM
BOTTOM UP AND STATE
SIMULTANEOUSLY SUPPORT
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO GAIN
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS
TO TOOLS LEGALLY APPOINTMENTS
FOR PATIENTS SO FOR US THIS WORK
LOOKS LIKE INVESTING IN LOCAL
LEADERSHIP. AND SUPPORTING
COMMUNITIES TO IDENTIFY THEIR
OWN NEEDS AND VISIONS DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIPS BUILD SKILLS AND
THEN ADVANCE THAT GRANTS
POLICIES ARE PROJECTS- SO TWO
PRIMARY RECOMMENDATIONS HERE-
NUMBER ONE IS TO DEVELOP
STRUCTURES FOR COMMUNITY
DECISION MAKING AND CORPORATE
GOVERNANCE. NO ONE KNOWS BETTER
THAN COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHAT ARE
NEEDED IN THEIR OWN
NEIGHBORHOODS IT REALLY OUR
COMMUNITY VOICES CENTER
ESPECIALLY IN THESE LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE DECISIONS-
CENTERED IN THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS SEE THAT IMPACT THEIR
LIVES. SO AGAIN HERE THAT THE
TCC PROGRAM THAT WAS SPOKEN OF
EARLIER REALLY DOES PROVIDE THE
STRONGEST MODEL THAT WE HAVE
SEEN. AT TCC PUTS COMMUNITY
LEADERSHIP FIRST REQUIRED
REQUIRING A COLLABORATIVE
GOVERNANCE MODEL AND BETWEEN
STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TECHNICAL
pRESIDENTS. THANKS WE ENCOURAGE
OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO FOLLOW
THIS MODEL AND REALLY ADOPT
MEANINGFUL COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND COLLABORATIVE. GOVERNMENT
GOVERNANCE REQUIREMENTS. THE
SECOND PC IS THE NEED TO SUPPORT
THE LOCAL EAGLES THAT CHANGE. SO
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS THAT- THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL COLLECTED IMPACT
IS REALLY DEPENDENT THE BALANCE
OF SEVERAL KEY STAKE TYPES-
STRONG COMMUNITY ANCHORS
SUPPORTED LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
THEN COMMUNITY FACING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AND THE BALANCE OF
THE STAKEHOLDER TYPES IS
CRITICAL AND WE THINK THAT THE
STATE HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN
APPROPRIATELY IDENTIFYING
SUPPORTING AND RESOURCING THESE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER GROUPS. SO
REALLY QUICKLY IN THE COMMUNITY
AND PER SIDE- YEAH THE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE RESIDENTS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS IN
PROGRAM DESIGN OUTREACH AND A
GREAT SELECTION. OF MANY GREAT
REQUIREMENTS- INSISTENTLY
PRIVILEGED PRIVILEGE
INSTITUTIONAL PARTNERS OVER-
WHAT GRASSROOTS MILLIONS AND AS
MANY NONPROFITS DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY OR THE INTERNET
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUSTAIN
RECENTLY SCREENING EXPERIENCE-
SO REALLY LOOKING FOR THE STATE
TO MOVE TOWARDS MODELS OF CO
GOVERNANCE FOR GOVERNANCE BY
DIRECTLY BY A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION SO THAT. THEY ARE
THE INTENDED RECIPIENTS OF
FUNDING- NUMBER TWO IS- YEAH THE
IMPORTANCE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RIGHT LOCAL AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENT ARE KEY ACTORS IN ANY
LOCAL INCONSISTENT. BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS
BEEN A KEY PERPETRATOR OF LOCAL
INEQUITIES LAND USE DECISIONS
AND PLANNING PROCESSES. SO THE
ENCOURAGEMENT HERE FOR THE STATE
ADD TO SUPPORT LOCAL AND
REGIONAL GOVERNMENT TO MORE
MEANINGFULLY ENGAGE RESIDENTS.
PARTNER WITH COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS AND PARTICIPATE IN
A COLLABORATIVE. PROCESS SEES.
EASING THE BAR PROVIDE ROBOTS
EQUITY STANDARD AND THEN LASTLY
HERE- KIND OF THIS YEAH. FOR
TECHNO ASSIST INTO- PARTNER- WHO
I THINK CAN OFFER MUCH NEEDED
CAPACITY MUCH NEEDED TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE TO SUPPORT COMMUNITIES
IN THEIR IN THEIR VISIONS AROUND
WHAT THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
THAT LOOKS LIKE. BUT THE OVERALL
AVAILABILITY AND QUALITY OF
TECHNICAL ASSITANCE AND VARIES
WIDELY ACROSS NEIGHBORHOODS SO
WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE STATE A
MUCH LARGER ROLE IN IDENTIFYING
SUPPORTING AND RESOURCING THESE
CRITICAL THIRD PARTY TO CHOOSE.
AND THE LAST- YEAH MENASCO
MINUTES- AT THE STATE MOVES
TOWARD EQUITABLE PROGRAM DESIGN
AND COLLABORATIVE GRANT T.
TEAMS- WILL ALSO NEED TO START
MEASURING FOR EQUITY SO HERE I
WANT TO FOCUSING ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF MEASURING. OUR
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIPS. EVEN
WITH ROBUST PROGRAM DESIGNED
STRUCTURE WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT.
IN REAL LIFE AND NOT JUST ON
PAPER- OPERATION OPERATIONAL I
THINK LAUGHTER GOVERNMENT'S JUST
MUCH MUCH MORE COMPLICATED
RIGHT- SO TO BALANCE POWER
DYNAMICS AND CALIBRATE THE
FUNCTIONING OF COULD MULTI
STAKEHOLDER GRANT T.
PARTNERSHIPS. LEADERS YOU'RE
RECOMMENDING THAT STATE
AGENCIES- FUND IN REQUIRED DEL
DEVELOPMENTAL LEARNING AND
EVALUATION OF THESE
COLLABORATIVE GRANTEE PROJECTS.
AND PARTNERSHIPS WE'VE HAD SOME
EXPERIENCE- ON OUR OWN WITH-
THIS KIND OF LEARNING EVALUATION
AND FOUND THAT HAVING AN
EXTERNAL EVALUATOR FOCUSED ON
EVALUATING FOR HARD TO MEASURE
CONCEPTS LIKE EQUITY BY CONTRAST
LAKE. IMPROVED OUTCOMES IN A
FURY OF CHANGE. THAT TO BE
ENORMOUS AND ARTSY PASTA
IMPORTANT AND- REALLY HELPFUL-
NEARING THE END OF MY TIME SO I
THINK I WILL STOP THEIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
AND I WILL THROW THE SNACKING
CARE. THANK YOU AND WE'LL COME
BACK FOR QUESTIONS IN A MOMENT A
NEXT. WE HAVE MS MEYER FROM SAN
BACK. THANK YOU. TRYING TO SHARE
A POWER POINT BUT IT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE SHARING IS ENABLED FOR
ME RIGHT NOW. I AM SEEING A
THUMBS UP FROM SOMEONE HERE SO
MAYBE TRY AGAIN. THERE WE GO.
THANK YOU ARE YOU ABLE TO SEE MY
SCREEN NOW YES. ALL RIGHT
EXCELLENT GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ANTOINETTE MY ARM THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF REGIONAL PLANNING AT
SANT'AGATA SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS WHICH IS THE
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATION AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCY
FOR THE SAN DIEGO REGION. AND
THE SAN DIEGO REGION CONSISTS OF
EIGHTEEN CITIES AND THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGOAND STANDEX PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO PLAN
DESIGN- BUILT AND FUNDS
TRANSPORTATION BUT PROBABLY- ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT THAT WE DO IS TO DEVELOP
THAT FEDERAL AND STATE MANDATED
LONG RANGE TRANSPORTATION PLAN
FOR THE REGION THIS IS REQUIRED.
I'M TO GET STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS AT SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO UPDATE EVERY FOUR YEARS
AND DECEMBER RE BOARDED OPTED
ARE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. REGIONAL
PLAN THAT'S TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL PLAN IS
QUITE DIFFERENT FROM ANY OF THE
PREVIOUS PLANS THAT THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED IT'S IT LOOKS OUT
THIRTY YEARS- AND IT IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT IN
TRANSPORTATION HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN TRANSPORTATION. HISTORICALLY
HAVE DONE PRETTY MINOR UPDATES
TO OUR TRANSPORTATION PLAN WITH
THE SAME THAT THE PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN IN THE PLAN FOR THE
LAST COUPLE OF DECADES- CONTINUE
TO BE THAT THE RIGHT PLANS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT TECHNOLOGY
HAS REALLY CHANGED FUNDAMENTALLY
TRANSPORTATION- AND IF WE WANT
TO BE SERIOUS ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO
INVEST AND- ROADWAY CAPACITY
INCREASING. PROJECTS SO WE
STARTED FROM SCRATCH WE WENT
THROUGH A VERY DATA DRIVEN
PROCESS AND WE DESIGNED A
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AROUND SIR
THREE GOALS ONE WAS REDUCING
CONGESTION BUT NOT BY EXPANDING
ROAD BASE BUT BY PROVIDING.
COMPELLING ALTERNATIVES TO THE
PRIVATE ON AUTOMOBILE-
ADDRESSING EQUITY BY INCREASING
ACCESS AND THEN MEETING OUR
STATE AND FEDERAL MANDATES AND
SPECIFICALLY- OUR STATE
REQUIREMENTS REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS BY 19% PER CAPITA
BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. WE HAVE
WE HAVE A LAW WAY TO GO ACHIEVE
GOALS TO AND THE SAN DIEGO
REGION 12% OF LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS LIVE WITHIN A HALF
MILE OF FAST AND FREQUENT
TRANSIT SERVICE. I MEAN THIS
REALLY THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE. AND
80% OF COMMUTERS ON OUR ROADWAYS
ARE ARE DRIVING ALONG WE WILL BE
ABLE TO FIX THAT PROBLEM- INTEL
WE HAVE COMPELLING ALTERNATIVES
TO DRIVING ALONE. AND I WAS
REALLY HAPPY TO SEE AN THE
RECENT PAPERWORK FOR THIS
HEARING THAT DIGITALIZATION- WAS
CONSIDERED AT TOOL. FOR
INCREASING SUSTAINABILITY AND
EQUITY TODAY IN OUR REGION WE
HAVE A DIGITAL DIVIDE WE SAW
FIRST HAND DURING THE PANDEMIC.
HOW THE LOOK THE FAMILIES THE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT WERE UNCONNECTED
AND UNDER CONNECTED I'M REALLY
CUT OFF FROM SOCIETY. STARVATION
THE PLAN FOR THE FIRST TIME
INCLUDES A DIGITAL EQUITY
STRATEGY AND ACTIONPLAN AS WELL
THAT SEEKS TO GET ALL
HOUSEHOLDS- ONLINE AND THE
SKILLS AND TOOLS THAT THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM
TECHNOLOGY. SOURCE STRATEGY FOR
ACHIEVING THE GOALS ON OUR PLAN
IS WHAT WE CALL THE FIVE BIG
MOVES THE FIVE BIG LIVES WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE A COMPLETE.
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM- STARTING
WITH A COMPLETE CORRIDORS
COMPLETE WHERE TO WHERE'S OUR
MULTIMODAL ROADWAYS THAT USED
TECHNOLOGY TO ACTIVELY MANAGE
HOW THEY'RE USED BASED ON REAL
TIME CONDITIONS AND THEY- THEY
ADDRESS CONGESTION IN TWO WAYS
FIRST THEY REALLY MAXIMIZE THE
INVESTMENT IN OUR EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. BY CONVERTING
GENERAL PURPOSE LANES THE
MANAGED LANES THAT GIVE PRIORITY
TO TRANSIT AND SHARED MOBILITY
HIGHER OCCUPANCY MODES. AND THEN
THEY PROVIDE THAT NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THOSE HIGH
SPEED HIGH FREQUENCY TRANSIT
LEAD SERVICE SAYS- BUT DO
PROVIDE A VIABLE AND COMPETITIVE
ALTERNATIVES TO THE CAR.
FLEXIBLE FLEETS THIS IS REALLY
BUILDING UPON THE POPULARITY OF
HALFPENNY BUILD SHARED MOBILITY
SERVICES WE'VE INCORPORATED-
EVERYTHING FROM SHARED BIKES AND
SCOOTERS TO MICRO TRANSIT. AND
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WORKING
UNDER THE ASSUMPTION THAT IT
EVENTUALLY THESE WILL BE-
CONNECTED ELECTRIC AND
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES AS WELL.
MOBILITY HUBS THIS REALLY
EMBODIES THAT FIFTEEN MINUTE
COMMUNITY THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT MOBILITY HUBS ARE
CONNECTED COMMUNITIES WHERE
THERE IS SAFE MULTIMODAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S EASY TO GET
AROUND I'M WITHOUT A CAR AND
THIS IS WHERE WE'RE FOCUSING.
OUR HOUSING AND COMMERCIAL-
GROWTH INTO THE FUTURE AS WELL.
AND THE LAST BUT NOT LEAST IS
WHAT WE CALL THE BRAIN OF THE
ENTIRE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THE
NEXT OPERATING SYSTEM THIS IS
THE TECHNOLOGY AND THE DATA THAT
WE USE TO MANAGE THE SYSTEM IN A
GREAT SERVICE AS PROVIDE BETTER
REAL TIME. INFORMATION AND AGAIN
THIS IS WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE A DIGITAL EQUITY
STRATEGY TO GO ALONG WITH OUR
PLAN BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY IS THE
WAY OF THE FUTURE AND WE WANT
EVERYONE TO BENEFIT. IN ORDER TO
GO FROM THESE HIGH LEVEL
CONCEPTS DOWN TO. ACTUAL
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK WE WENT
THROUGH. A PROCESS OF LOOKING AT
HOW PEOPLE WANT TO WE NEED TO
MOVE AROUND THE REGION AND THIS
IS ONE EXAMPLE THIS IS WHERE
PEOPLE LIVE AND WORK IN THE SAN
DIEGO REGION TODAY- THE MAP ON
THE LEFT THERE WITH THE PINKS
AND PURPLES- IS POPULATION
DENSITY THE DARKER THE COLOR THE
MORE PEOPLE LIVING IN THOSE
AREAS. THE BLUES THE MAP WITH
THE BLUES IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
THESE ARE REPLACEMENT CENTERS
THIS IS WHERE THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF JOBS ARE WITHIN
THE REACH AND- AND ON THE MAP ON
THE RIGHT USES- BOTH CENSUS
DATA. AND CELL PHONE DATA- TO
LOOK AT WHERE PEOPLE ARE COMING
FROM TO ACCESS THESE JOB
CENTERS. AND THEN WE DID THIS
KIND OF ANALYSIS FOR YOU KNOW-
ALL OTHER TYPES OF ACTIVITY
CENTERS- EDUCATION OUR MILITARY
BASES WHICH WE HAVE QUITE A FEW
IN THE SAN DIEGO REGION
RECREATIONAL DESTINATION SO WE
GOT A REAL GOOD SENSE. FOR WHAT-
CONNECTIVITY'S NEEDS WERE AND
THE SAN DIEGO EACH I. MEAN
BEYOND LOOKING AT DATA LIKE THIS
WE ALSO WENT THROUGH. A ROBUST
OUT PROCESS WE PARTNER WITH AND
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS SO THEY CAN
HELP BRING THE SOCIAL EQUITY
PERSPECTIVE TO US. GET THE WORD
OUT ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
GET INPUT BACK TO LAST ON WHAT
UNITY'S. NEED OUT OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. SO THIS
ALLOWED US THAN TO- TRANSFORM
THESE CONCEPTS INTO A COMPLETE
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK STARTING
WITH THE MOBILITY HUBS- ADDING
IN OUR- COMPLETE CORRIDORS THE
MANAGED LANES RAPID TRANSIT
SERVICES. IMPROVING OUR LIGHT
RAIL THAT EXIST TODAY SPEEDING
IT UP. AND THEN ADDING COMMUTER
RAIL WHICH IS THAT HIGH SPEED-
SERVICE THAT- I'LL- WE DON'T
HAVE IN THE REGION TODAY. BUT
THEY CAN MAKE THOSE LONGER
CONNECTIONS QUICKER FOR PEOPLE.
AND THIS ALLOWED US TO NOT JUST
MEET BUT EXCEED OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION REDUCTION TARGET BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. ENDS OUR OUR
HOUSING GOALS FOR ADDING A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
MORE THAN A HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND NEW HOMES AND MOST OF
THOSE HOMES ARE BEING ADDED
WITHIN THOSE MOBILITY HUBS. AND
YOU CAN SEE HERE- THAT A LARGE
PART OF LOW INCOME MINORITY-
SENIOR POPULATIONS- ARE LIVING
WITHIN THOSE MOBILITY HUBS IN
THE YEAR TWENTY FIFTEEN MORE
THAN THAN FIFTY PERCENTS- OF OUR
SOCIAL EQUITY COMMUNITIES WILL
BE AND I'M ABILITY HOUSES HAVE
THAT ACCESS THOSE TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES. SO THIS IS- TODAY.
WHAT ARE ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION- AND YOU'LL SEE
BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE WE'VE
INCREASED THAT- SUBSTANTIALLY
AND BY TWENTY FIFTY EVEN MORE SO
WE GO FROM. NO 12% OF LOW INCOME
POPULATION HAVING ACCESS TO HIGH
SPEED TRANSIT UP 2401% MODE
SHARE ALSO IMPROVED
SUBSTANTIALLY- YOU'LL SEE AND
THE TANK THERE THAT WE HAVEMORE
PEOPLE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF US
MANAGED LANES AND CARPOOLING AND
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN PEOPLE
TAKING TRANSIT WALKING AND
BIKING- FOR THEIR COMMUTE. SO
THAT IS THE END OF THE
PRESENTATION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS AND HAVING
MORE OF A DISCUSSION THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU IN SANDAG. NEVER
DISAPPOINTS. YOU KNOW WHAT DO
GREAT WAY TO END OUR
PRESENTATIONS WITH A PLAN THAT
RECOGNIZES THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION AND MOBILITY. AND
DOESN'T OVER EMPHASIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF ELECTRIFICATION OF
TO THE TRANSPORTATION MODES BUT
REALIZES THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT
BUT THAT'S NOT A TRANSPORTATION
PLAN. AND THAT DOESN'T SOLVE ANY
OF OUR OTHER ISSUES- I GUESS I
WOULD ASK- YOU BOTH. ABOUT
AGAIN- SORT OF METRICS AND
EVALUATION AND I WOULD ALSO ASK
WELL. LET ME JUST START WITH
SAND ACCENTURE ON THE SCREEN-
WHETHER YOU FEEL THAT YOU'RE
GETTING THE SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE THAT THAT YOU NEED- IN
TERMS OF THESE RESOURCES THAT
WE'VE BEEN HEARING FROM THE
OTHER AGENCIES WHETHER. FINDING
OUT ABOUT THEM ACCESSING THEM
HAVING COMMUNICATION WITH THE
STATE WITH YOUR STATE PARTNERS.
AND I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT YOUR
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES I MEAN
THE STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE
ADMINISTERING THESE GRANTS
WHETHER THAT'S HOW THAT'S BEEN
GOING FOR YOU I'M NOT TRY TO PUT
A ONE SPOT I THINK WE'RE TRYING
TO IDENTIFY PLACES THAT WE CAN.
HELP AND IT TO IMPROVE. WELL I
WOULD SAY WE HAVE- WONDERFUL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH ALL OF THE
STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY- WE HAVE
GRANTS FROM VARIOUS AGENCIES-
WORK COLLABORATIVELY ON- GETTING
RESOURCES TO OUR MEMBER AGENCIES
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WITH THE
STATE- AND SO- ALL OF THE
AGENCIES. REUTERS TO STAND ACT-
YOU KNOW LOOKING FORWARD WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO- WE NEED A
LOT OF FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT OUR AMBITIOUS PLANS-
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING- TO PARTNER AND- MAKE
GOOD PROGRESS- ON OUR ARE VERY
AMBITIOUS VISION FOR
TRANSPORTATION- IN TERMS OF
METRICS THE SECOND PART OF YOUR
QUESTION. WE HAVE. YOU KNOW
CLOSE TO THIRTY OR FORTY
DIFFERENT INDICATORS- AND WE ARE
EVALUATING- OUR PROGRESS- AND
PUTTING OUT REGULAR MONITORING
REPORTS FOR THE REGIONAL PLAN
BUT SANTA IS ALSO INVESTING IN
AN OPEN DATA PORTAL SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE- DATA THAT WE COLLECT
AVAILABLE TO- THE PUBLIC WE
WANT. YOU KNOW TRANSPARENCY WE
WANT TO SHOW- HOW WE'RE DOING-
AND SO THAT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO LAUNCHING THAT AT
PUBLIC DATA PORTAL HERE PRETTY
SOON. GREAT THANK YOU AND HAVE A
QUESTION FOR MS WEIGHING FROM
GREEN LINING INSTITUTE AND
ACTUALLY TWO QUESTIONS ABOUT US
ASK THEM TOGETHER THE FIRST ONE
IS THAT YOU HAVE UP ALWAYS GREAT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND YOU. YOU ALL
AS AN ORGANIZATION SPENT A LOT
OF TIME REALLY ANALYZING WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN MAKING. VERY SOLID
RECOMMENDED AND I'M WONDERING IF
YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE GETTING
ANY TRACTION OUT THERE DO. YOU
FIND A RECEPTIVE YOUR FROM OUR
AGENCIES WHEN YOU MAKE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS SUCH AS HOW
GRANTS ARE ADMINISTERED- WAYS OF
CHANGING SERVE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE. AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION IS WHETHER YOU THNK
WE'RE PUTTING ENOUGH RESOURCES
INTO TCC GIVEN THAT YOU'VE CITED
SEVERAL TIMES AS A VERY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM SO THAT WOULD
BE FOR I GUESS FOR EITHER OF
YOU. YEAH HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
YOUR FIRST QUESTION I WOULD SAY
THE CHALLENGE OF MANY OF THESE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS IS
THAT- IT'S A DECENTRALIZED
PROCESS RIGHT ALL THESE
DIFFERENT BASKETS KIND OF
DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES SO I
WOULD SAY. OVERALL OVER THE
YEARS WE HAVE FOUND INCREASING
RECEPTIVITY TO THESE KINDS OF
IDEAS AROUND AND THE NEED TO
EMBED EQUITY AND OPERATIONALIZE
EQUITY AND WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE AND WHAT THAT MEANS. THAT
BEING SAID- YEAH I MEAN THE
STATE AGENCIES ARE A REALLY
LARGE BUREAUCRACIES IT IS LIKE
IT'S LIKE PUSHING AN ELEPHANT UP
THE HILL- BECAUSE CHALLENGING TO
WORK THROUGH NOT ONLY PROGRAM
DESIGNED BUT ALSO SOME OF THE
LIKE INTERNAL ADMINISTRATIVE AND
BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS SEES. THAT
I THINK MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
COMMUNITIES TO ADAM. TO WORK
RIGHT AND SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE
CITED TCC MANY TIMES- WE HAVE
PROBABLY A VERY- YEAH WORKING
WITH THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL IN PARTICULAR- AS AN
INTER AGENCY BODY AS AN AGENCY
THAT I THINK IS. SMALLER AND
MORE NIMBLE IS ABLE TO TAKE ON
KIND OF MORE CREATIVE PROBLEM
SOLVING AND THATIS WHY WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO WORK WITH THAT
AGENCY IN PARTICULAR AND ALSO
THERE- ABILITY. TO THE STC
COUNSEL TO THEN HOPEFULLY-
PROPAGATE OUT SOME OF THESE
IDEAS ARE ON OPERATIONS IN
EQUITY SO THAT'S TO THE FIRST
QUESTION- YEAH LOTS OF
CHALLENGES ENGAGING WITH STATE
AGENCIES I THINK SOME FOLKS ARE
RECEPTIVE I THINK SOME FOLKS ARE
NOT. I THINK THE FOLKS WOULD
LIKE TO BE RECEPTIVE TO THE
WORKING THROUGH THESE THESE
LARGE PROPERTIES IS. NO SMALL
pQUESTION- AROUND- TRANSFORM IT
CONTINUES PROGRAM. I THINK THE
RECENT BUDGET ALLOCATIONS BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS FROM THIS YEAR AS
PROPOSED BUDGET AS WELL AS LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ARE APPROPRIATE.
WE'VE ALWAYS ENVISIONED TCC TO
BE ABLE TO FIND CATALYTIC LARGE
SCALE GRANTS ALWAYS ENVISIONED
EVERY GRANT CYCLE WOULD HAVE
THREE TO FOUR GRANTEES GRAB
AWARD EATS. AND THE RECENT
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS IN THE RANGE
OF YOU KNOW A HUNDRED MILLION TO
TWO HUNDRED MILLION I THINK
ACHIEVES THAT. THE CHALLENGE HAS
BEEN IN PREVIOUS YEARS OF
FUNDING- WHEN AT TCC HAS NOT
SEEN ANY. FUNDING OR HAS
RECEIVED ONLY TEN MIN AND ALSO
FIND. I'M BACK IN CONCERT. IN
PAST YEARS- BEEN PRIMARY CHANNEL
AND IS. A THE PRIMARY CHALLENGE
FROM OF THESE OPPORTUNITIES-
THEY'RE ASKING COMMUTER TO PLAY
HOMELESS. FOR THEM. BUT THEN THE
FUN SORTS ITSELF THE- THAT YOUR
TEACHER BUDGET ALLOCATIONS
ITSELF- DON'T HAVE CONSISTENCY
BUILT INTO AND THEREFORE IT'S
HARD FOR TO ME NEEDS TO BE ABLE
TO COUNT. ITS RESOURCES HERE A
YEAR. THANK YOU THAT IS VERY
VERY HELPFUL SO I THINK I WOULD
ASK IF ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
STILL PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND
HAVE A QUESTION MAYBE TO TEXT ME
OR SOMEHOW. SIGNAL US THROUGH
ZOOM- AND IF I DON'T HEAR FROM
ANYONE I THINK WHAT I'LL DO IS
SAY THANK YOU TO OUR PANEL SO I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY. TEXT ME RIGHT
NOW. THEY SAY THANK YOU TO THE
PANELS AND WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT SO- THANK YOU PANELS AND
IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WHO WISHES TO GIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT IF YOU WANT TO MOVE UP
TO THE MICROPHONE NOW THIS WOULD
BE THE TIME. OKAY SEEING NONE DO
WE HAVE ANYONE COMING OPEN THE
PHONE LINES UP THIS WOULD BE THE
TIME FOR ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT BY TELEPHONE
TO. GO AHEAD AND CALL IN AND
WITH THAT I'LL ASK. IF THE PHONE
LINES CAN BE OPEN. WE HAVE AN
OPERATIC YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LEADING. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON TODAY'S
CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER.
AND WHEN YOU'RE LINE NUMBERS
CALLED PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE LINE. DO
YOU HAVE TWO PARTIES IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU AND
WE WILL GIVE THE PHONE- COLORS
TWO MINUTES WHICH IS A 100% MORE
THAN A NORMAL TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. AND NINE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THINK HE'LL AND MEMBERS AND
PRESENTERS FOR UPLIFTING THE
NEED FOR EQUITY ACROSS
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING LOCAL
ECONOMY AND DEVELOPMENT
PROPERTIES AS NECESSARY
COMPONENT OF BUILDING. MATERIAL
COMMUNITY- AND MODIFIED MEN WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY- ADDITIONALLY
THAT WE DO NEED COORDINATION
BETWEEN LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
REGIONS AND STATE GOVERNMENT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE KIND OF
EFFECTIVE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
EMBED ACCOUNTABILITY INTO
PROGRAM DESIGN AND AT THE SAME
TIME SUSTAIN LONG TERM POSITIVE
PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS GOVERNMENT.
HE CAN BE DONE TOGETHER AND THE
NEED IS PARAMOUNT PROMISING
STATE STRATEGIES LIKE AT THE ACT
HAVE FALLEN SHORT IN PART DUE TO
THE LACK OF COORDINATION AND
ENFORCEMENT BETWEEN ALL LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT WE'RE ALSO SEEING
A LACK OF POLITICAL WILL AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO MEANINGFULLY FUND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PLANNING AN
ADAPTATION. COORDINATION AND
MUTUAL ACCOUNTABILITY ACROSS
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO BUILD
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
ADDITIONALLY THERE MUST BE
EQUITY ACROSS GEOGRAPHIES THAT
CS FRAMEWORK DOES NOT WORK FOR
RURAL COMMUNITIES THE SCENARIOS.
DEVELOPED VICTORY IS THE ANTI BY
INVESTING IN TRANSPORTATION ONLY
AND HIGHER DENSITY AREAS AND
LOCAL COMMUNITY EFFORTS ARE
CONTINUOUSLY CHALLENGED BY NPR'S
ONLY INTERESTED IN SUSTAINING
OUR PATHETIC WELL LIKE WE CAN
FRESNO COUNTY'S CURRENT MEASURES
THE OUTSKIRTS WITCHER-
PRIORITIZING THAT WAY EXPANSION
. REMAINS THE TREMENDOUS GAP
AND- IF YOU LOCALLY AND HELPFUL
I COULD DEVELOPMENT PERSON TO
LOCAL IN HOUSTON AND- EAT IT.
ESPECIALLY THE SEPARATE HERE
TODAY. NEED TO BE ON THE- OF
CHALLENGE AND GUESTS AND DEADLY.
DEVELOPMENT AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO GENERATIONS OF ECONOMIC AND
HELP SACRIFICE. THE PARENT IN
AREAS OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WHERE TOXIC INCLUDING LAND USE
THAT CONTINUE TO BE CITED IN
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND
ACTIVELY UNDERMINE THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO BUILD SUSTAINABILITY
FOR COMMUNITY STATEWIDE. THERE'S
ALSO A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
MAXIMIZE THE WORK OF FUNDED
PROGRAMS. BY COORDINATING GOLD
INVESTMENTS AND ACTIVITIES OF
VARIOUS PROGRAMS. JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES OF PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM A MORE HOLISTIC
APPROACH. TO BUILDING
SUSTAINABILITY OUR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS PROGRAMS
EXTREME HEAT INVESTMENT AND
BUILDING OCCUPATION ALL OF WHICH
NEED TO BE UNIFIED BY A
COMMUNITIES VISION FOR
TRANSFORMATION TO IMPLEMENT.
FINALLY WE AGREE COMMUNITIES
MUST BE ENGAGED IN THE PROCESS
OF COMMUNITY- TRANSFORMATION
FROM PROJECT INCEPTION TO
IMPLEMENTATION CAN NOT GET TO
ENSURE BUY IN FROM COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. YEAH WHAT MISTRUST OF
GOVERNMENT APART. OKAY YES FOR
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE COMMUNITY'S
VISION OF SUSTAINABILITY AN
ECONOMY AND THE ALL PARTY TO
UNIFIED INVENTING VISION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CALL K. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LONG IS OPEN
PLEASE GO. AND THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. I WANTED TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF OUR STREETS WERE ALL-
YOU KNOW BASICALLY IN
APPRECIATING THE CONVERSATION
NOTHING HAPPENED YOUR RECORD
LAND USE POLICY I'M NOT PART OF
THE REASON THAT- WE KNOW WE'RE
SUPPORTING BILLS FASHION NOT
REALLY ENCOURAGED THAT BETTER
LAND USE. POLICY INCLUDING THEM
REMOVE THE- AND THAT- AND ALL-
HI THE OTHER BILL THAT WE ARE WE
ARE STARTING A LOT OF THE L. SIX
Q. Q. ICHI THREE SEVEN BECAUSE-
REALLY THINKING ABOUT THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. THAT
ANYONE I WANTED TO THROW INTO
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT. THAT I
WISH WE COULD TALK MORE ABOUT.
THE FIGHT HE- IS THAT A LOT OF
WHAT MAKES GOOD LAND USE POLICY
AND I CRIME AND ENVIRONMENTAL
AND A LITTLE WHAT THE DEFENSE
ALSO MAKES GOOD LAND USE POLICY
ON A FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE AND- A
LOT OF ARCADIA THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY ARE- GOING FISCALLY- ARE
NOT THIS WEEK'S OPENED. UP THE
COUNTRY NOT THAT CALIFORNIA IS A
MULTIMEDIA UNTIL HELLO I SMALL
THIRTY YEARS- ACROSS THE LOW
DENSITY SAID HE- BECAUSE THE
AMOUNT OF RESPECT A CHOIR
CONSISTING. ALL. WHAT THE CITY
IS THAT AND BANK I'M NOT
ENCOURAGE ANOTHER LITTLE ON
BACKPACKS ENCOURAGE. ANYONE IS
LISTENING TO THE CALL. IF YOU
WANT TO GO THE FINAL TO GO TO GO
OUT LIKE THAT FISCALLY. THING TO
DO. TO KEEP SMALL CITIES FIRE A
LOT AND SUPPORT THEM THROUGH
GOOD LAND USE. THAT IS ALSO READ
TO THE- IS REALLY LOOKING AT THE
THAT WAS JUST TODAY BY A GROUP
OUT BY. OF. WE'LL TAKE SAW THE
STRONG HOW. PRINCIPLES AND- THEM
INTO HE IS. AND ALLOW. AT THAT
HOW THE ATTACK THOSE ARE. KEEPER
ORGANIZATION AND BRAWL. AND- YOU
KNOW BECAUSE THE AREAS THAT THE
COURT- YEAH. STANLEY HOW
NEIGHBOR. AND HOW TO ACTUALLY
MAKING A- HOME. A LITTLE BIT
MORE. PRODUCTIVE AND INTERNAL
MAKE THEM MORE CREDIBLE CLIMATE
. ANYBODY REALLY. AND POSTING IS
THAT I THINK HE ME OUT. AND
WOULD A LOOK AT THAT YEAH. YEAH
STRONG YOU CAN ON THE DAY REALLY
REALLY SOLIDIFIES THE IMPORTANT.
IN- AND ECONOMIC THANK. BEYOND
JUST BE MORE CLIMATE CHANGE
AFTER THAT SEEMS LIKE OF THE CAR
. WITHIN LEGISLATURE TALK ABOUT
THAT. ALAKNANDA ON THE PART OF
THE MOTHER. I REALLY DID A LOT
DISCUSSION BE BY FAR. NEEDED IT
COULD. BOTH TRIED TO BE. ON THE
FISCAL. AND THE CLIMATE. AND I
WE CAN BY SOMETHING THERE THAT'S
ALL I HAVE TO SAY YOU. THANKS
MUCH FOR CALLING IN. OPERATORS
OR ANY ELSE ON THE LINE. WE DO
HAVE ONE FINAL CUT. AND MYND
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO OUT.
I YOU GOING I REMEMBER THE WAS
MY DAY CAL BEACH HERE TO CALLING
INTO THE COMMITTEE FOR EVER THEN
. CONVERSATION TODAY. ARE
PERFECT ACCOUNT BE A ON THIS IS
REALLY BEEN FOR THE LAST YEARS
THAT WHERE THE STATE IDENTIFIED
A KEEN IN EITHER DAN HOW GOAL OR
DID A CRIME. THE BILL. SHOULD
IT'S INSTABILITY TO OPREA LOCAL
RULES THAT RUN CONTRARY TO THOSE
GOALS SO WE'VE IT. I WE BEEN
TRYING TO OF THE STATE LEVEL
PREEMPTION BURKE WHAT DOWNEY-
LOCAL USE RULES I END UP LOOKING
. ROLES TO FURTHER THOSE GOALS I
WOULD JUST CONSIDER BREAKERS THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION I HAVE A
COMPUTER HOW TO HOW TO MAKE
BEHIND IT AND. AND HOW THEY WORK
TOGETHER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OPERATOR IS THERE ANY OTHER
CALL. WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU I WANT TO
ONCE AGAIN THANK MY COLLEAGUES-
WHO ATTENDED AND I WANT TO
THANK- PRIMARILY THE PANELISTS
WHO GAVE SO MUCH OF THEIR TIME
AND THEIR EXPERTISE AND WHO
WORKED SO DILIGENTLY ON ALL OF
THESE ISSUES AND I WANT TO
ADDITIONALLY THINK A GOVERNOR
NEWSOM BECAUSE- I THINK THAT HE
WERE THERE ANY GOVERNOR I'VE
EVER SEEN. A SEEMS TO HAVE A
REAL GRASP OF THESE ISSUES AND
IS PRIORITIZING CLIMATE AND
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING- IN A
WAY THAT'S VERY REFRESHING AND
VERY MEANINGFUL- FOR THESE
CHALLENGES WHICH ARE SO HUGE FOR
OUR STATE SO THANKS AGAIN TO
EVERYBODY AND THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IS NOW COMPLETE.